PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR TAKING
YOUR SEATS IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW. THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO. HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE. INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT SEVEN SIX EIGHT
NINE. FOUR ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. AND OR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
STYLE ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU TO A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE UN MUTED.
AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
GIVE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO JUST DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTE. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES MAY BE HEARD.
WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WE WILL ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SESSION.
IN ADDITION. SO BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS. AND
ADOPT THE RULES LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONE
ON. ROTH HERE ROTH HERE
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ HERE
ARCHULETA HERE ARE TO LETTER
HERE BEATS. BAKER YOUR- HERE
WORKER HERE DODD HERE THANK GOD
HERE EGGMAN HERE LET ME HERE
HER TADO. JONES LEYVA HERE
LEAVE A HERE IN. AND HERE MANY
HERE. HERE YOU MANY HERE BUT
CHAU BOGUS HERE UNTIL ABOUT
HERE PAYING HERE. CAN HEAR. A
QUORUM BEEN ESTABLISH. OUR
FIRST OF BUSINESS TO IS THE OF
OUR RUE WITHOUT A THE
COMMITTEE RULES WILL BE ADOPTED.
OUR FIRST ITEM OF BUSINESS.
WELCOME CEREMONY YOU HAVE ONE
BUILT TODAY S. B. FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ALSO REYES DISEASE IS
GROWING PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ZACKS IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO ALZHEIMER'S
INCREASED TWO HUNDRED AND 43%
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
ALZHEIMER'S WAS THE THIRD
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH.
ACCORDING TO THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION LESS THAN HALF OF
THE INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S HAVE BEEN GIVEN A
DIAGNOSIS THE LACK OF A
DIAGNOSIS LEADS TO A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES RELATED TO PLANNING
CARE COST OF CARE AND
ENGAGEMENT IN CLINICAL TRIALS.
WHILE THE STATE HAS A GERIATRIC
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS AND HAS FUNDED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TOOLS TO HELP
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS DIAGNOSE
FOR ALZHEIMER'S IT CHALLENGES
IN RECEIVING A TIMELY AND
ACCURATE ACCURATE DIAGNOSIS
CONTINUE TO PERSIST. FOR
EXAMPLE ANY SURE MY SURVEY
CONDUCTED BY THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION REVEALED THAT
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS THE A
GROWING ISSUE PRESENTED BY
DEMENTIA AND FEEL UNPREPARED
MORE THAN HALF SAY THEY ARE NOT
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH DEMENTIA
CARE SPECIALIST IN THE AREA TO
MEET PATIENT DEMAND AND NEARLY
39% REPORT THAT THEY ARE NEVER
OR ONLY SOMETIMES COMFORTABLE
MAKING THE DIAGNOSIS OF
ALZHEIMER'S OR OTHER DEMENTIAS.
SB EIGHT MORE IMPROVE THE
ABILITY OF CALIFORNIANS TO
RECEIVE A DIGNIFIED DIAGNOSIS
AND QUALITY CARE FOR
ALZHEIMER'S AND DEMENTIA
SPECIFICALLY SB FORTY EIGHT
WOULD REQUIRE PROVIDERS TO
COMPLETE AT LEAST FOUR HOURS OF
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
CME. ON ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA EVERY TWO YEARS.
CALIFORNIA ONLY HAS FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN GERIATRICS
FOR SPECIALISTS TO CARE FOR THE
FIVE POINT EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE
AGE SIXTY FIVE AND ABOVE. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT ALL AFFABLE
PROVIDERS OBTAIN THE NECESSARY
TRAINING I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION IS
COMMITTEE AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE THAT THE CONTINUING
MEDICAL EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
ARE BALANCED. MY STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS HAVE ALREADY HAD
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
SEAT AND THE MEDICAL BOARD. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS IN THE COMEDIAN
ANALYSIS WHICH CLARIFY THE
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS AND
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL TO
ONLY APPLY TO GENERAL
INTERNISTS FAMILY PHYSICIANS
AND PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR WE WILL
NOW MOVE INTO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION WELL I HEAR
ANYTHING BACK ON AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURES. NOW WE WILL
HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY. I SEE NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL. FORTY
EIGHT. I SEE NO YEAH. HELLO.
WE'RE HELLO WE'RE TALKING NOW
TO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL FORTY EIGHT I'VE
NOTED NO WITNESSES. IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE- LOS IS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
HELLO HELLO WE'RE HERE PART.
THIS IS THE- EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR WHAT WHEN CALLED UPON
TO SPEAK FROM THE SPECIFIC ROOM
THAT THE CHAIRPERSON IS
REQUESTING WE JUST NEED ONE
PERSON AT A TIME AND PLACE YOU
SHOULD BE A BUTTON WHEN NOT
SPEAKING. ARE THERE WITNESSES.
SEVERAL OTHER WITNESSES AND
SENATE ROOM ONE TWELVE. NO
WITNESSES IN ONE TWELVE SO WE
WILL NOW MOVE INTO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE OF ITS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FORTY
EIGHT WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND AS INSTRUCTED
BY THE CHAIR PERSON IF YOU DO
WISH TO COMMENT AT THIS TIME AS
INSTRUCTED PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR WE
DO HAVE PEOPLE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU.
WE. THANK YOU I HAVE. PRIMARY
YEAH I MET ON THE- CAN YOU HEAR.
MISTER MODERATOR COULD HANDLE
AND PART OF ME. ONCE AGAIN
RIGHT NOW WE ARE TAKING
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC. IF
YOU WERE YOUR LINE IS OPEN AND
YOU ARE WITNESS- PLEASE MAKE A
NOTE OF WHICH BILL IT IS THAT
YOU'RE HERE TO DISCUSS. JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT MISTER. WHEN YOU
HAVE A CHANCE MISTER MODERATOR
WHICH PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL. FORTY EIGHT. HOW WHY DID
YOU WHAT. MISTER THE IS THE A
ANTI OP- WE DO HAVE A THIS TIME
FIVE PEOPLE WHO WERE SHE TO. AT
THE TIME WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LAW FORTY ONE YOUR LINE ITSELF.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. LINE
FORTY ONE MINUS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING- IS CAN I A LIVE IN
CITY NICE FOR SO AS FORTY EIGHT
BECAUSE THE TIMING DARK IN CARE
FOR BY AN S. TOOLS RENDON THE
AND CARE GIVE TO MAKE DISDAIN.
ABOUT MANAGEMENT FINANCIAL AND
LEGAL MATTERS WHEN MY MOTHER IN
LAW BEGAN EXHIBITING SYMPTOMS
OF ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE HE DID
NOT RECEIVE A DIAGNOSIS SO I AM
VERY WELL AWARE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE THAT THE
DIAGNOSIS WOULD OF MADE IN HER
LIFE AND MY FAMILY'S LIFE BY
YOUR TO SUPPORT S. B. FORTY
EIGHT FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL.
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW GO TO LINE FORTY TWO LINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS FRED MAY.
REPRESENTING CARAPACE THE
PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY WHICH PROVIDES
REAL SENIORS. FIFTY FIVE YEARS
AND OLDER. INTEGRATIVE CARE AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO
LINE FORTY EIGHT. YES NINETY
AND I LIVE IN. MY FATHER DIED
ABOUT THE I HERE FOR THE ALL
DISEASE AND I AM NOT. SB FORTY
THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA AND NOW
GO TO LINE. FORTY HELLO MY NAME
IS CHRIS I LIVE IN A CAL. I'M
NOT I'M NOT SURE CARE GIVER OF
LIFE WHO OUTSIDE THE AND STILL.
I'M KICKING CARE OF HIM BUT I
COULD AND FORTY EIGHT AND GLAD
THIS IS BECAUSE- YOU KNOW I HAD
TO SWITCH DOCTORS ACROSS TIMES
BY MY FATHER DOCTOR SUPPOSED BE
IN. WITH A COMES TO OUR MIND
NEVER SHOWED SUPPORT NOW TOOK
THE TO AYE SUMMARY NOTES.
EXPLAINED TO THE STATE OF MY
AND HE ANY KIND OF. UNDERSTANDS
ACTUALLY MEANT AND HOW THE WILL
YOU TO PUT TO BE PART THE DIED.
AND NEVER EXT. TO- WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DEALING AND IT WOULD
TO HELP TREAT MY FATHER BEHAVE.
AND YOU KNOW ONE MIGHT I EVEN
FIELD CAME WITH THAT CHOOSE SEE
THAT WITH THAT THE ONE WHO
BROUGHT THE BLOOD OUT AND YOU
KNOW WHY NEVER HAD ANY SUMMER
NOTES WHEN HE CAME TO MY DAD
DIED AND THEY HAD DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENT. THEY ALSO DOLLARS-
I DON'T SPEAK TO MY FATHER AS
IF HE'S NOT THERE YOU KNOW HE'S
NOT DEAF HE HE HAD OUR PRIMERS
AND SO I FEEL I'M MORE TRAINING
FOR THE DOCTORS IS DEFINITELY
NEEDED BECAUSE THEY HAD NO IDEA
HOW IT AFFECTS THE FAMILY- ONE
DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT IS OVER
THERE IS STILL STILL MORE THAT
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH AND SO WE
FEEL REALLY AT A LOSS WHEN IT
COMES TO GOING TO THE DOCTORS.
SB FOUR EIGHT WILL HELP US- YOU
KNOW WHAT- GET FEEDBACK
TRAINING DOWN TO THE DOCTORS
WHEN IT COMES TO- LIKE NOT JUST
THE FINANCIAL PART BUT
SPECIALLY AND THE RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED THE ALCHEMIST
ASSOCIATION ACTUALLY- THAT WAS
MOST IMPORTANT TO US AND BUT
THE ONLY THING IS. THEY DON'T
PRESCRIBE MEDICATION OBVIOUSLY
BUT- I. OTHER RESOURCES WERE
MORE HELPFUL THAN THE DOG I
GUESS MY POINT. AND SO AND THE
FORTY MODESTO HELP ALONG THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR WILL. BE GO TO.
LINE FOR. LAKEPORT LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MARK QUITE
I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO MY WIFE
DOES IT ALZHEIMER'S TWO DAYS
BEFORE THANKSGIVING TWO YEARS
AGO I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IN ALZHEIMER'S
RESEARCH. NEXT. A MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR MISTER CHAIR WE'RE GOING
TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT NO ONE IS OPEN.
CHRIS READ IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL- I'M ON SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF BIOGEN THIS IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED TO BILL INTO SIMPLE FIX-
MORE EDUCATION WILL HELP THE
DOCTORS HELP THE FAMILIES. IT A
SOLUTION AT A FOUNDATIONAL
LEVEL WE ASK FOR YOUR I. D.
THANK YOU NEXT. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR OF SENATE ALONE IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU HAVE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES ON A
LINE. THAT THANK YOU CHAIR THAT
IS CORRECT WE HAVE CARLA PRIOR
PATIENT ADVOCATE AND JARED.
YOUR RUSSO- FROM THE
ALZHEIMER'S IT DISSOCIATION
THAT WERE OUR PRIMARY AND-
WITNESSES AND THEY ARE STILL ON
THE LINE. LET'S HEAR FROM THEM.
THIS IS YOUR DIRECTOR FOR THE
ALZHEIMER'S AND WHAT I'M JUST
WAITING FOR CARLA- I NEED SHE'S
A PERSON THAT.
GIVEN THAT KARLA
MIGHT BE HAVING SOME ISSUES
WITH OUR PHONE I THINK I'LL
JUST GO AND THEN MAKE A FEW
POINTS AND THEN IF YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO- I'M HERE YEAH
THE OPERATOR HEAD. CHIMED IN
AND SAID SOMETHING OKAY I'M I'M-
LET ME JUST REMIND EVERY WE
HAVE A MANA A ON- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION SO.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND SENATORS MY
NAME IS CARLA PRAYER AND I AM
THE SOLE CAREGIVER FOR MY
HUSBAND AND ADVOCATE VOLUNTEER
FOR THE ARMY ASSOCIATION I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATE DIDN'T
LEVIN BOTHERING SB FORTY EIGHT
LEADING THE WAY IN I DIDN'T
IDENTIFYING POLICY BECAUSE
PROPOSALS THE BILL WHO HELP
WITH DEMENTIA TODAY I'M HERE TO
SHARE OUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH GETTING A DIAGNOSIS FOR MY
HUSBAND. THAT'S WHAT THE VERY
LOW CARING PERSON WHO BELIEVE
IN LAST WORKING AND TAKING
PRIDE CARRY PERMITS. I NOTICED
MY HUSBAND CHANGING. IT MEMORY
CHANGING AND TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN HE CALLED ME AND ASKED
ME TO MEET HIM AT THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE. WHEN I WALKED UP TO HIM
YET YEARS AND I JUST. WAS
ADAMANT I CAN'T GO BACK TO WORK.
I AGREE BECAUSE I FELT THE
STRESS WAS GOING TO KILL HIM.
AFTER A FEW MONTHS OF GOING TO
WORK. GOING TO GOING TO WORK
AND GOING TO PSYCHIATRISTS
ANGER MANAGEMENT CLASSES
DISTRESSING TO GET BETTER.
DESPITE OF ALL THE LONG
GRUELING DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT.
BUT THEY THEY SAID THEY WERE
RELEASING HAD TO GO BACK TO
WORK. AT TEN THE PANIC STYLE
ALL OVER AGAIN. SO IN MAY OF
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN PATRICK
RETIRE FROM BEING A OPERATING
ROOM NURSE OVER THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS AT AGE FIFTY EIGHT. HI
HONESTLY THOUGHT THIS WAS THE
ANSWER. AND THAT HE WOULD
DELIVER GRAIN HAS MEMORY WITH
PATRICK B. IN THE PRIMARY
BREADWINNER. WE HAD TO SELL
EITHER SQUARE THREE THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT HOME AND MOVE INTO
A TWO BEDROOM. SEVEN HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT APARTMENT. AFTER
WAS IT DIDN'T. DISABILITY
CAUCUS. THANK OF TIME BECAUSE
THE DOCTORS COULD. TO SAY.
CONDITIONS LOUD CRACK IN THE
IMPAIR. FINALLY FOUR YEARS
LATER WAS TIRED OF GOING. THE
GOING ABOUT THE RUN AROUND. AND
TAKEN OUTSIDE OF THE NETWORK TO
STANFORD HOSPITAL. THEY DID
SOME TESTING ON HIM AND SEE IF
IT WOULD CLEAR THAT THIS LOOK
IMAGE I TOOK STAFFERS TO PASS
DR AND THEN MADE A TO ORDER A
PET SCANS THAT SHOWED LITTLE
ANYBODY. WHAT WAS MRE
TROUBLING THAN THAT. IS THAT
THE TESTING THE PERSON DOING
THE TESTING SENATE THAT MY
HARDWORKING HUSBAND WAS. TAKING
SINCE ALL THIS I HAVE CLOSED
ALLOW REALLY IS MUCH UP WITH AS
POSSIBLE. TO GET A CARE MY HAS.
THE ONE STOP HUSBAND WHO HIM
AND TAKING KEEP RIGHT CARE OF
IN THIS. I KNOW CARE FOR HIM.
WE ASK PLEASE SUPPORT S. FORTY
EIGHT TODAY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT GOOD MORNING-
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND- MA'AM MANY
DURING THE DELIVERY QUICKLY
MAKE- ARE SPECIAL FROM YEAR IN
THESE LAST WEEK WITH THAT ACT
EXACTLY ISSUE IN RECENT CARE
THE REPORT FOUND OTHER WITH
RESEARCH CONDUCTED BY BIRTH
FOUND THAT 50% OF BLACK AND 40%
NATIVE AND TO MY THIRD OF ALL
AMERICANS ELECT KNOW THE THIS
WERE SEEKING OUT TO HELP CARE
AND ONE COUPLE THAT HEALTHCARE
THIS WITH HELP THE- OF HIGH
RATE THE ALZHEIMER'S FOR
DIVERSE COMMUNITY. WERE LEFT
WITH WHERE FAR TOO MANY
INDIVIDUAL HAVE THE OF LIKE
CARL HER HIGH WERE ASKING YOU
ALL TO KEY INTO VOTING THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTRETTA READ WE PLEASE CHECK
THE ONE MORE MAKE SURE WE'VE
HEARD. ALL WITNESSES SUPPORT OF
SO BILL FORTY A- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
AND THAT'S GOING TO COME FROM
LINE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JULIE
POLANSEK I LIVE IN NORTH HILLS
CALIFORNIA. I AM A VOLUNTEER
WITH THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION DRIVEN TO DO THAT.
AS A RESULT OF THEIR KERR. ALL
PART IN EDUCATING ME WITH B.
CARE OF MY GRANDMOTHER HER
PRIMARY DOCTOR DID NOT GIVE US
A DIAGNOSIS. UNTIL OVER TWO
YEARS AFTER DEALING WITH HE AND
THEN OUT OF THE EMERGENCY ROOM
ALL OF THIS REALLY COULD HAVE
BEEN AVOIDED AVOIDED HAD THERE
BEEN PROPER- FIVE INSIGHT FROM
THE BEGINNING AND SB FORTY
EIGHT SPEAKS TO THAT VERY
CLEARLY. IT'S REALLY A NO
BRAINER AND I JUST URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE HOLD IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
MR MODERATOR. MISTER CHAIR I
BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
PERSON WHO'S JUST SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. WE WILL NOW GO. TO AND
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE FIFTY
FOUR LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON S. B. FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS JACKIE SEVEN ITEMS
FROM SAN MATTEO CALIFORNIANS MY
BROTHER HAS ALZHEIMER'S. BY
SUPPORT AND STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL OF THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION LET'S
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY. AND I SEE NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL FORTY
EIGHT I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM. ONE TWELVE. WE WILL NOW
MOVES TO THE WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS. WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SENATE BILL. FORTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
FORTY SIX LINE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS ARE
INVOLVED WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA FIRST ELECTED TO
GIVE A CLEAR SIGN THAT THE
BOARD HAS NOT TAKEN A POSITION
ON THE BILL HOWEVER DURING ITS
LAST MEETING THE BOARD MEMBERS
VOICED CERTAIN CONCERNS SENATE
BILL FORTY EIGHT. PORT IS
CONCERNED THAT PHYSICIANS
SHOULD HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO
CHOOSE CONTINUING EDUCATION
MOST APPROPRIATE TO THEIR
PRACTICE AND THAT MANDATING
CERTAIN COURSEWORK BY STATUTE
MAINLY TO FUTURE PRESSURES TO
DO SO ON OTHER MATTERS AND
POTENTIALLY CROWD OUT OTHER
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS THE
CONDITIONS FACED AS THEY SERVE
THAT PARTICULAR PATIENT
POPULATION. ON THIS TOPIC
MISTER CHAIRMAN AS OF ALL OTHER
AREAS OF PRACTICE THE BOARD
EXPECTS LICENSEES TO ADHERE TO
THE STANDARD OF CARE WHEN
TREATING THEIR PATIENTS
CONTINUING EDUCATION IS AN
IMPORTANT PART TO ENSURE THE
POSITION TO MAINTAIN THEIR
CONFIDENCE. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE OFFICE OFFICE.
OFFICER FOR THE POSITIVE
DIALOGUE SO FAR THAT WE'VE HAD
OVER THESE LAST WEEK AND WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE-CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU. NEXT. WHY. THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MR CARE
MEMBERS OPERATE DOUGHERTY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS.
IT'S RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB
FORTY EIGHT UNLESS IT'S AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATELY RECOGNIZE THE
THIRTY OF THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA SET EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AND THE
FLEXIBILITY POSITIONS NEED.
AGENTS BENEFIT FROM THEIR
CONTINUING EDUCATION. WE
CERTAINLY SHARE THE AUTHOR'S
GOLDEN SHARING THAT PATIENTS
SUFFERING FROM ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA RECEIVE APPROPRIATE
AND TIMELY CARE BUT WE BELIEVE
SB FORTY EIGHT ONE FORTUNATELY
NOT THE CHEAPEST LAW INTENDED
GOALS. CURRENTLY CRAFTING.
REALLY MEDICAL EDUCATION
CURRICULUM BE BY DEMONSTRATES
CLINICAL AND READ NOT DICTATE
BY STATE. FURTHERMORE POSITIONS
COME. COURSE NEXUS TO BEST MEET
THE NEEDOF THERE'S PATIENT
PANEL BETTING AND- WELL EACH
WITH TEN IS THERE A- TO THEIR
PATIENTS. THE MOST APPROPRIATE
AT TO DETERMINE THE OVERALL
POSITION EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS IT IS ABOUT
QUARTER CALIFORNIA AT SUCH CITY
AREA HE ASKED THAT. QUESTION.
TWENTY ONE NINETY FOUR. CHECKS
SHOULD BE OF THE BEAVER.
FOLLOWING SUCH BE AT. BUT ONE
NINETY ONE SIX. AND SHOULD WE
INTO TO. CONTINUING
REQUIREMENTS BOARD SHALL
CONSIDER INCLUDING A COURSE ON
THE SPECIAL CARE NEEDS OF
PATIENTS WITH DEMENTIA. LOS OF
MY MINUTES ALSO CAN WITH
BUSINESS PERFECT CODE SECTIONS
ONE NINE ONE FIVE WHICH ALSO
GIVES MEDICAL DISCRETION IN
DETERMINING AND CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS. FOR
INTEGRATING MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH CARE IN PRIMARY CARE
SETTINGS ESPECIALLY AS IT
PERTAINS TO EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND EXPOSURE TO TRAUMA
IN CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS-
MORE CALIFORNIA'S RECENTLY
RELEASED MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
STATES THAT. ONLY ABOUT 5% OF
PROVIDERS IN GENERAL. AFTER
TRADING INCLUDING IN A SPACE
SMALL PERCENTAGE PROVIDERS WHO
HAVE ALREADY PARTICIPATED IN
THIS TRAINING OUR FAMILY
PHYSICIAN. AS PART OF A FAMILY
PHYSICIANS RESIDENCY TRAINING
MUST ALSO COMPLETE A MINIMUM OF
ONE THIRD. OR ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE HELLO. YOU KNOW I'M
A PRETTY LIBERAL GUY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE TIME BUT WE'VE RUN
OVER THE TIME HERE SO COULD YOU
PLEASE WRAP UP. SURE FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WERE ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE ON. SB FORTY EIGHT A
MONTH IT'S AMENDED HIS PROPOSED
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE THREE MINUTES
BUT- IT'S NECESSARY BELIEVE ME.
NEXT THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN TO
SPEAK MR CARE. MISTER MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. ONCE AGAIN FOR ALL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER CARE.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR THANK
YOU TO ALL THE WITNESSES WHO'VE
TESTIFIED WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO. MEMBERS ON
THE FLOOR MEMBERS. DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
REGARDING SENATE BILL. FORTY
EIGHT- FIRST TRUST NOTICE
CENTER EGGMAN. BUT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR HI I GUESS THE
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR WHY TAKE
THE ROUTE OF MANDATING THE- THE
COURSE VERSES AS AS THE
OPPOSITION SUGGESTED LETTING
THEM MEDICAL BOARD DECIDE IF
ONE IS NEEDED OR NOT. THREE
THANK YOU AND YOU KNOW OUR OUR
INTENT IS THAT IS TO ENSURE
THAT FOLKS HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION BECAUSE IT'S OFTEN
THE PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS- AND
IN THE FAMILY POSITIONS THAT
FIRST SEE- THE INDIVIDUALS AND
SO. IT IS YOU KNOW PART OF THE-
THE MASTER PLAN I THINK AFTER
SEEN THE IN MASTER PLAN ON
AGING AND HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS-
ARE HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE
NOT GETTING DINERS WE NEED TO
GET DIAGNOSED AND SO ARE OUR
INTENT IS REALLY TO SAY LOOK
THIS THIS SHOULD BE. SOMETHING
THAT EVERYONE HAS SOME
FAMILIARITY CERTAINLY WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR THE GENERAL
SPECIALIST FOR FAMILY
PHYSICIANS TO BECOME A
SPECIALIST IN ANYWAYS- WE JUST
WANT SOME UNDERSTANDING AND
THIS COMES ALSO FROM SURVEYS
FROM THE DECISIONS THEMSELVES
SAYING THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TRAINING OR INFORMATION.
I KNOW THAT I'VE HEARD FROM
POSITIONS AT THE I'D ABSOLUTELY
WELCOME IT'S NOT MY SPECIALTY
BUT I'D WELCOME KNOWING
SOMETHING AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO IDENTIFY WHAT IT WOULD LOOK
LIKE- AS YOU KNOW THIS BILL WAS
JUST INTRODUCED THIS IS THE
FIRST HEARING SO WE'RE STILL IN
CONVERSATIONS TO IDENTIFY. ANY
THE CONVERSATIONON WHETHER IT
SHOULD BE SHALL OR YOU KNOW- OR
MAY I THINK IS PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION OF WHAT WILL IT
CHEAP AND WE'RE OPEN TO HAVING
A CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT IT IS
SHE'S AT THE END BECAUSE THE
OUTCOME IS FOR MORE PEOPLE TO
BE DIAGNOSED. AND I WOULD. AND
I KNOW YOU ARE AN AUTHOR AS A
LEAD. IN I BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORKING ON
I KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT- AND WITH
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. BUT PAN. THANK YOU- FAIR
AND- FIRST OF ALL I DO
APPRECIATE- THE AUTHORS GOALS
AND THE SPONSORS SCHOOL OF-
TRYING TO IMPROVE- SCREENING
AND- AND MANAGEMENT OF- PEOPLE
WITH DEMENTIA- AND HOWEVER I DO
HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE APPROACH
WHICH IS TO MANDATE CONTINUE
EDUCATION IS NOT THE
APPROPRIATE ONE OR DEFECTIVE
WAY OF GOING ABOUT DOING THIS
FACT IN THE PAST THIS COMMITTEE
HAS- GENERALLY- DISCOURAGED-
MANDATING CONCERNING EDUCATION
BECAUSE OUT AS A MEDICAL
EDUCATOR I TELL YOU THAT ADULT
LEARNING PRINCIPLES BECAUSE WE
WANT TO PLAY EVIDENCE TO OUR
POLICIES. FIGLEY SAY THAT FOR
ADULTS THAT SELF DIRECTED
LEARNING IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO FOR PEOPLE TO LEARN SO
MAKING SOMEONE SIT THROUGH A
CLASS THAT THEY THEMSELVES- DID
NOT CHOOSE BUT ARE REQUIRED TO
IS NOT A VERY EFFECTIVE WAY OF
TRYING TO- TO IMPROVE THEIR
THEIR SKILLS SAID IN FACT I
THINK THE I APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY FROM SUPPORTERS BUT
I'M NOT SURE THIS IS THE RIGHT
SOLUTION. HOWEVER I WOULD SAY
THAT- THAT THE ANSWERS ARE THE
DRAWCONTRAST ACTUALLY IS FOR
EXAMPLE- WE'RE TRYING TO
IMPROVE- BECAUSE PETERSON WE'RE
TRYING TO PROVE SCREENING FOR
ADVERSE HEALTH EVENTS- SO WHAT
WE HAVEN'T DONE IS MANDATE THAT
PEDIATRICIANS AND OTHER
PHYSICIANS TAKE YOUR CHILDREN
ARE MANDATED TO SIT THROUGH S.
C. C. COURSE ABOUT ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EVENTS BECAUSE SOME
ACTUALLY ARE FAIRLY FAMILIAR
JUDGE THEREFORE CHOOSE HOWEVER
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS WE'VE
ESTABLISHED OUTCOME MEASURES-
THROUGH OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM
WE'VE- ALSO. SET QUALITY
STANDARDS AROUND THAT AND I
HOPE THAT THAT'S THE APPROACH
THAT THE- THE PROPONENTS MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER AS AN
ALTERNATIVE SIDE THAT BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY THE OUTCOME THAT
MATTERS IT'S NOT THAT SOMEONE
DID SOMEONE TO OF COURSE AND
TAKE. THAT OFF THEY SAT THROUGH
A COURSE INHOPEFULLY. AND
FORTY THIS IS ALSO A HAVING SAN.
THIS AND WE CAN ABOUT WIFE OUR
VERSUS HOURS OR SIX HOURS- AND
IT'S EVERY TWO YEARS. THAT
SOMEONE DOES IT JUST TAKE THE
SAME COURSE EVERY TWO YEARS IN
ORDER TO CHECK OFF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF WE'RE NOT
EXACTLY- THREE OR KNOWLEDGE OR
ACTUALLY TAKING AWAY THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO THAN TO TAKE
COURSES AND OTHER THINGS THAT
THEY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT. SO I
APPRECIATE- THE AUTHORS- GOALS
I WOULD CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD
TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO- TO- TO
WORK WITH YOU A CERTAIN AMOUNT
ON THIS BUT FORTUNATE. CANNOT
SUPPORT THE BILL AS IT IS AT
THIS TIME BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS AND
I HOPE THAT- THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE. BECOME
FRUITFUL AND THAT WE CAN.
REALLY LOOK AT A BILL THAT
ACTUALLY WOULD IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR- OUT PATIENTS WITH DEMENTIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATE-ROOM. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THE CEREMONY I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON THIS BILL- MY
FAMILY HAS HAD A DIRECT AND
VERY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH
ALZHEIMER'S- AND ACTUALLY IT IT
COMPLETELY CORRESPONDS TO THE
SCENARIO OUTLINED. MY WIFE'S
MOM. WAS. ASSESSED IN
IMPROPERLY DIAGNOSED FRESHLY
THREE YEARS BEFORE FINAL
DIAGNOSIS WAS ACTUALLY MADE
CLEAR THAT FALSE DIAGNOSIS
UNFORTUNATELY GAVE MY FATHER IN
LAW THE HOPE. THAT HIS BELOVED
WIFE WAS NOT SUFFERING FROM
DEMENTIA AND AS A RESULT HE
FOUGHT THAT PROCESS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS AND AS A CONSEQUENCE- NOT
ONLY WAS HER CARE LESS THAN
IDEAL BUT THE FAMILY LOST
PRECIOUS TIME. WITH THEIR MOM
SO I UNDERSTAND YOU'VE OFFERED
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS- AND I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THAT I COMMEND YOU
ON THIS BILL AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR RICHMOND FORD. THANK
CENTER NEWMAN CENTER OF YOUR
MAKEUP. I WANT TO THANK
COLLEAGUE FOR I THINK THIS IS I
WANT TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM FOR
SHARING THAT- PERSONALS IN I
WANT TO ECHO HIS SENTIMENTS
ABOUT. THE GOALS OF THIS BILL-
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY INCREDIBLY
LAUDABLE- I HAD A QUESTION A
COUPLE QUESTIONS JUST THE FIRST
WITH THIS BILL AS WRITTEN A
PLIGHT OF PEDIATRICIANS. RIGHT
NOW THE RIGHT NOW THE BILL-
ONLY APPLIES. TO FAMILY
PHYSICIANS PHYSICIANS
ASSISTANTS AND GENERAL
INTERNIST NOT. ALL OKAY JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE JUST BECAUSE MY
STAFF WAS NOT CLEAR FROM THE
LANGUAGE IF IT MIGHT ALSO
PLAYED PETERSON'S. AND I THINK
I WOULD JUST- ECHO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE OPEN AMENDMENTS AND
THAT'S WONDERFUL JUST AROUND-
TAILORING THE BILL JUST
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW I HAVE A
NUMBER OF PHYSICIANS IN MY
FAMILY AND I THINK THAT THEY-
WOULD ECHO SOME OF DR PANTS
AND- I'M SORRY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SACRAMENTO'S CONCERNS-
JUST AROUND- ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AND SO JUST MAKING
SURE THAT. IT THE BILL IS
TAILORED AND SO THAT THOSE WHO
MIGHT BENEFIT FROM THIS ARE THE
ONES RECEIVING IT WOULD BE.
AMAZING BUT. I THANK YOU FOR
PROPOSING THIS BILL. I THINK
IT'S- THANK YOU SO MEN MEMBERS
pOTHER. CENTER JONES. I THINK
ANY OF TWO OTHER MICROPHONES UP
AS WELL MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO SHARE THE- I SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION ON
THE BILL SO I ALSO WON'T BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT I DO
WANT THE FOLKS KNOW THEY'RE
PROPOSING A BILL. THAT YOU KNOW
I ANNUALLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
ALZHEIMER AWARENESS DAY I'VE
GOT TO THE PURPLE SASHES IN MY
OFFICE RIGHT NOW- SO WE'LL KEEP
UP THE EFFORTS OF- OF THAT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE
CONCERNS- I WON'T BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU- CENTER JONES
CENTER HER TITLE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND THREE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK THAT THERE'S A REAL ISSUE
TO ADDRESS HERE. AND BUT I
THINK IT ALSO- I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS REGARDING THE BILL AND
HOW AND HOW IT'S BEING
ADDRESSED I THINK WE DEFINITELY
NEED TO HAVE A GREAT A
CONVERSATION AROUND MEDICAL
EDUCATION MEDICAL TRAINING AND
CONTINUING EDUCATION- AND- I
REALLY WANT TO WORK- WITH THE
AUTHOR MOVING FORWARD BUT AT
THE MOMENT DOES THE BILL STAND
TAKEN NOT SUPPORTED. BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND MOVING THIS FALL
ALONG THE WAY FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER
OF TROUBLES. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK- I WOULD LIKE TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
FORTH SUCH AN IMPORTANT BILL AS
SOMEONE WHO- HAS BEEN
PERSONALLY TOUCHED IN OUR
FAMILY WITH- WITH ALZHEIMER'S
AND DEMENTIA I THINK THE
GREATEST CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
THAT IT TOOK OVER TEN YEARS.
FOR OUR FAMILY MEMBER MY
GRANDMOTHER IN THIS CASE WHO I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE
WITHIN MEXICO- WAS DIAGNOSED
BEFORE SHE WAS DIAGNOSED AND
THERE WAS A LOT OF HARM THAT
HAPPENED IN THE PROCESS OF. NOT
BEING DIAGNOSED BECAUSE WE DID
NOT FIRST OF ALL WE'RE NOT VERY
AWARE OF ALZHEIMER'S OR
DEMENTIA AND- AND IT CREATED A
LOT HAVE ACT. IN IN IN THE
FAMILY SO. I DO APPRECIATE THE
BILL'S I DO UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS OF DOCTOR PAN HOUSE.
BUT I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THE- AUTHOR-
HAS IN REGARDS TO AMENDING IT
SO THAT IT DOES. ACCOMMODATE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE DO NEED MORE
AWARENESS IN THE MEDICAL.
PROFESSION ESPECIALLY THE ONES
THAT ARE IN DIRECT CONTACT WITH
OUR WITH THE- WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE
ALZHEIMER'S DEMENTIA SO I THINK
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
AWARENESS AND DEFINITELY MORE
TRAINING IN. AND DIAGNOSING
THE- THE- THE DISEASE WHICH
STARTS VERY VERY LIGHT YEAH.
INNOCUOUS SO- WITH THAT THOUGH-
THANK YOU THANKS TO THE AUTHOR
FOR WILLING TO WORK IN AND
ACCEPT AMENDMENTS AND IF SHE
WOULD ACCEPT A CO AUTHOR BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO SIGN ON TO
THIS BILL. AND I DO MOVE- WE
HOPE TO MOVE THIS AT BILLBOARD.
THANK YOU MA'AM CENTER BECKER.
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
POINT THAT THIS IS A GROWING
PHENOMENON AS WE LIVE LONGER
SAYS MR RIGHT NOW ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF THOSE EIGHTY FIVE AND
OLDER. HAVE ALZHEIMER'S AND
I'VE HEARD ESTIMATES UP TO
EIGHT ONE HALF OF FOLKS EIGHTY
FIVE AN OLD OLDER WILL GET
ALZHEIMER'S THIS IS INCREASING-
THE INCREASING ISSUE AND I
THINK THIS LEGISLATION IS VERY
TIMELY. AND I THINK THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD. I YES
I'D LIKE TO ALSO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS-
FORWARD FOR THE REASONS MY
COLLEAGUES OF ARTISTS-
DESCRIBED. I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THIS ISSUE ABOUT
MAKING THIS COURSE REPEATED
EVERY TWO YEARS I DID NOT SEE
THAT ANALYSIS I MAY HAVE MISSED
IT. BUT I THINK I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE AUTHOR WOULD TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT- MOVING FORWARD
AND- YOU KNOW WILL WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION ON THAT. POINT
THANK YOU CENTER DOT ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. SO ALONE I GUESS I
HAVE A QUESTION AND A COMMENT I
GUESS THIS- THIS IS CERTAINLY.
TOUCHED US ALL AND IF IT HAS
ENDED WILL I. MY MOTHER IN LAW
AND MY UNCLE BOTH PASSED FROM
ALZHEIMER'S ALZHEIMER'S RELATED
COMPLICATIONS SO- I'M ACUTELY
AWARE OF THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
AS OBVIOUSLY ARE MY COLLEAGUES
IN MANY MANY MANY. THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY MY QUESTION IS
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
OSTEOPATHIC PHYSICIANS- IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
CERTAINLY ELSEWHERE PROBABLY
THOUSANDS OF THEM ARE PROVIDING
PRIMARY CARE TO RESIDENTS IN
OUR STATE- EVERY DAY- WAS THERE
A REASON THAT- OSTEOPATHIC
PHYSICIANS- WERE LEFT. OUT OF
THE EDUCATION REQUIREMENT
REFERENCED IN YOUR BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHAIR YOU KNOW WE
AGREED THAT MORE PEOPLE YOU
KNOW MORE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WOULD INCREASE THE
UNDERSTANDING BUT WE DID WANT
TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL- AND WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT. THE FOR PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS ARE FOR SO MANY THE
FIRST STOP IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE CAN AND CONSIDER
OTHERS BUT I THINK IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO NARROW AND
GIVEN THE FEEDBACK OF THE
COMMITTEE I WE ARE HAPPY TO
COMMUNICATE- WITH OTHER
PROVIDER GROUPS TO POTENTIALLY
INCLUDE THEM IN THE FUTURE- BUT
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW OUR GOAL IS
TO START SOMEWHERE- AND I THINK
THAT THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
WITH THE BILL GENERALLY IT.
STARTS SOMEWHERE AND IT GIVES
US POLICY TO DISCUSS AND WE'RE
VERY OPEN TO AMENDMENTS WERE
OPEN TO HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO REACH THE OUTCOME-
THAT WE ALL WANT AND SO.
CERTAINLY AGAIN WE'RE OPEN WE
SAW IT IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND ARE OPEN TO
DISCUSSIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND AS YOU MOVE HOPEFULLY MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD- THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE YOU AND YOUR
TEAM WILL TAKE A LOOK AT THE-
PRIMARY CARE THAT OSTEOPATHIC
PHYSICIANS ACTUALLY PROVIDE ON
A DAY TO DAY BASIS IN THE STATE
AND- AND TAKE A LOOK AT
INCLUDING. OSTEOPATHIC
PHYSICIANS- DEOS. ARE WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF YOUR BILL. CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU. SO I WANT TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES AND I WHO ARE
SUPPORTING AND THOSE WHO HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERNS THIS IS A
FIRST STEP- SO I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS BUT I ALSO HOPE. THAT
WE COULD SEE A WAY TO SUPPORT
THIS BECAUSE WITHOUT THE BILL
WE DON'T HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW WE CAN GET TO THE END
GOAL. I CERTAINLY I WELCOME ALL
OF THAT THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE
BEEN SEPARATIONS AND EXPRESSED
YOU'D LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
FIND A WAY AND ALSO VEHICLES TO
ACHIEVE THE OUTCOMES AND HAPPY
TO CONTINUE WORKING. OUT WITH
THOSE OF YOU WHO I WOULD LIKE
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE I AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THE BILL AS
AMENDED HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL DO YOU PASS OF AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO RE REMIND
YOU TO PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONE ON. ROTH HI ROTH AYE
MELENDEZ AYE. MELENDEZ AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ARCHULETA AYE
BEATS. BAKER HI BAKER HI DODD
HI DODD AYE EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
AYE HER TADO. JONES NO JONES NO
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE MAN BY MIN
AYE NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE A
SHOW ABOUT OPEN HI A TERRIBLE
GUY HANDS.
THE VOTE IS TEN IS
ONE- WILL HOLD THE BILL OPEN
FOR- ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
WELCOME SENATOR DODD YOU HAVE
ONE BILL TODAY SENATE BILL. TWO
SIXTEEN. THIS IS YOUR NOW THAT
I MADE IT INTO THE- TO THE
MICROPHONE. THIS WAS A TEST IS
A TEST I FAILED AT MISERABLY.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. EVERY YEAR 55% OF
LICENSE CONTRACTORS CLAIM TO
HAVE NO EMPLOYEES AND FILE FOR
AN EXEMPTION FROM HAVING
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE
FOR THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD. HOWEVER THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
IN RESEARCH IN ENFORCEMENT CASE
DATA DEMONSTRATES THAT MANY
CONTRACTORS ARE FALSELY MAKING
THAT CLAIM. THIS DRIVES UP THE
COST OF WORKERS COMPENSATION
INSURANCE FOR THE GOOD ACTORS
IT PUTS WORKERS AT RISK WHEN
THEIR PLAYER LACKS SUCH
INSURANCE. SB TWO SIXTEEN WILL
HELP PROTECT WORKERS IN
PRECLUDE THE FILING OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION EXEMPTIONS FOR
CONCRETE. HVAC IN TREE SERVICE
CONTRACTORS AND BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WILL REQUIRE ALL
CONTRACTORS TO MAINTAIN WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE.
REQUIRING ALL CONTRACTORS TO
HAVE WORKERS COMPENSATION
INSURANCE WILL PROTECT WORKERS
WHO WERE INJURED ON THE JOB
WHETHER THEY'RE WORKING FOR THE
CONTRACTOR FOR A DAY A WEEK OR
FULL TIME IT LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR LAW ABIDING
CONTRACTORS. THE SYSTEM. THE
SYSTEMIC PROBLEM OF CONTRACTORS
CLAIMING AN EXEMPTION EVEN
WHILE HAVING EMPLOYEES HAS LED
TO UNFAIR INCREASES IN WORKERS
COMPENSATION FOR COMPLY
CONTRACTOR EMPLOYEES IN EXPOSES
WORKERS AND CONSUMERS TO
PHYSICAL AND FINANCIAL RISKS
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD IS MICHAEL JIM THAT SKI.
THANK YOU A SENATOR AS WE
PREVIOUSLY NOTED EACH SIDE WILL
ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY SHOULD LIMIT
TESTIMONY TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES PLEASE PROCEED. DO WE
HAVE SOMEONE PRESENTING FROM
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD. OKAY EARLY- CENTER
THEY'RE NOT ON THE LINE JUST.
IS UPS OKAY WHICH PROVIDES NEXT
I HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. GOOD MORNING SHARE
MEMBERS MIGHT CHEN THAT HE FOR
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD THE BOARD IS PLEASED TO
SPONSOR SB TWO ONE SIX. AS THE
SENATOR STATED- EVERY YEAR 55%
OF LICENSE CONTRACTORS TO FILE
AN EXEMPTION CLAIMING THEY HAVE
NO EMPLOYEES AND THE
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS DO
BEAR OUT THAT MANY OF THEM IN
FACT DO. SO THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE OF ALLOWING A
LICENSED CONTRACTOR TO FILE
EITHER PROOF OF INSURANCE OR AN
EXEMPTION HAS NOT BEEN
EFFECTIVE. NOW THE BOARD IS OF
COURSE COMMITTED TO EXERCISING
ITS LIMITED AUTHORITY IN THIS
AREA AS IT STANDS IT TO PROTECT
WORKERS AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC IT DOES SO BY TAKING
ADMINISTRATIVE OR CRIMINAL
ACTIONS AGAINST LICENSED OR
UNLICENSED CONTRACTORS. WERE
FOUND TO HAVE EMPLOYEES BUT
HAVE NO COVERAGE IN PLACE.
EVERY YEAR THEBOARD DOES ISSUE
HUNDREDS OF STOP WORK ORDERS OR
LEGAL ACTION FOR HAVING A FAULT
EXEMPTION ON FILE- BUT AFFORD.
THIS HAS NOT MOVED THE
PROVERBIAL NEEDLE AS A NUMBER
OF EXEMPTIONS THAT REMAIN
CONSISTENT EVERY YEAR. AND THE
BOARD IS SIMPLY NOT STAFF TO
AUDIT THE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND OR SO
CONTRACTORS WHO CLAIM NOT TO
HAVE EMPLOYEES. SO WITH THAT
SAID- WE APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. I SEE NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTEEN. SEEING NONE. WE WILL
NOW MOVE INTO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SERVICE
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
BEGIN TO PROPPED INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT%
OF SENATE BILL TWO SIXTEEN WE
WILL BEGIN. UHHUH. OKAY. MISTER
MODERATOR. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
EXCUSE ME MADAM MODERATOR. KATE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
HAVE WHICH TO- HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT- YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WE'RE GOING FIRST TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE THAT PLANE
THREE FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR HERE MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS CHRIS WALKER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SHEET METAL
AND AIR CONDITIONING
CONTRACTORS. I'D LIKE TO FIRST
THANK UNDERDOG WE'RE OFFERING
THIS BILL- THIS DOES IMPORTANT
TO CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE UP 250%
OF EACH RAT CONTRACTORS IN THE
STATE SAY THEY DON'T HAVE
EMPLOYEES- THAT NONSENSE. AND
WE NEED TO CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE
THANK YOU. Q. NEXT. THANK YOU
WE GO NEXT TO MY THIRTIES LINE
THREE SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN.
pMITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL FROM
THE WRITTEN PREVIOUSLY STATED
WHICH VERY QUICKLY ADD THAT
HAVING HELPED WORKERS THROUGH
THE UNINSURED EMPLOYERS
BENEFITS TRUST ONE. THE VERY
TOP PROCESS THAT OFTEN DOESN'T
END WITH THE WORKER GETTING THE
BENEFITS THAT THEY NEED THIS IS
A GREAT SOLUTION WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT. THANK
YOU WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FOR
SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR THE SILVER
MEDAL IN REPRESENTING THE FLASH
OF THEIR KIDS SO SHE- THIS IS A
ISSUES NEAR AND DEAR TO THE
ENTIRE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
SPARKED. AND WE ARE ACTIVELY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND
URGED THE COMMITTEE I BURKE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. NOW
GO TO LINE FIFTY NINE LINE
FIFTY NINE PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT. FIVE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RICHARD MARCUSSEN ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
DIALECTICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. ALL THE
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. ONE FORTY TWO. PARDON
ME LINE NINETEEN. MISTER TURN
NUMBERS CAN BE DONE HERE DURAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL BELIEVERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NECKLINE. THIRTEEN
FINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIRMAN THE
LAND IS GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
THIS IS KEPT ON WITH THE
AMERICAN SUBCONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR DODD FOR.
PRODUCING AN OVERDUE BILL
ACTUALLY. THE BILL- GREATLY
CURB THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
BECAUSE SOME CONTRACTORS DON'T
REVEAL ALL THEIR EMPLOYEES AND
THEY PREMIUMS. FOR WORKERS
COMP. STUDENT WORKERS COMP. IN
AND SEARCH THEIR BIG COSTS ARE
LOWER THAN THAT UNFAIRLY
COMPETES WITH OTHER LICENSEES
WHO DO COMPLY WITH THE LAW.
WORST WE'RE NOT REPORTING
PROPERLY A WORKER'S INJURY MAY
NOT BE COVERED. AND SUCH WE
BECAUSE CSO BE TOOK ALLOW OF
MONEY ON THIS IS INVESTIGATOR.
INJURY CLAIMS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU
NEXT FIND. ONE THIRTY FIVE.
PARDON ME WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE THIRTY SEVEN. FIND. FORTY
SEVEN. MISTER TERRY AOLOGIZE
FOR THE DELAY HERE WE'RE GOING
TO ATTEMPT LINE. NINETEEN JUST
A MOMENT MISTER CHAIR. OUR NEXT
STEP PERSON Q. AS LINE NUMBER
FIFTY THAT FLYING FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CALM SHE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OFFER BRINGING IT FORWARD BUT A
PER SHARE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WE
HAVE FUN NEXT LINE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
HELLO MR TESTER DOT PROJECTION
BUT THIS IS A BRUTAL TRICK ON
THE AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
APPLICANTS ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE. BUT A MODERATOR WILL
YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTEEN. YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
JOIN THE QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT YEARS ONE
THEN IF ZERO. MISTER TERRY
DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE QUEUING
UP PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. LET'S BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY AND I
SEE AND NONE I THE GALLERY
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SEE IF THEY'RE ANY
THERE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTEEN THERE ARE NONE WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY. VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE URBIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD BEGIN PROMPTING
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTEEN WE WILL BEGIN.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEY PAD AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO
THANK YOU.
MISTER TERRY HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO ALL
THE WITNESSES WHO DID TESTIFY
WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO- THE MEMBERS
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS REGARDING THE BILL.
OKAY SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I GUESS I JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR AND
I THINK WE'VE ALL. BEEN
EXPERIENCING. SURE PROJECTS
AROUND THE HOUSE THAT WE'VE
HIRED CONTRACTORS FOR. THEM
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS- IF SOMEBODY
IS JUST A ONE PERSON
CONTRACTING ASSOCIATION- ONE
PERSON BUSINESS. WELL IF IT. HI
MAY- THE YOU KNOW- ALLOW THE-
YOU KNOW THE GENTLEMAN FROM
STATE CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD
TO OPINE ON THIS BUT BY MY
READING OF THIS IS IF THEY
LEGITIMATELY ARE A ONE PERSON
OPERATION THAT THEY WOULD
EITHER BE GET EXACT OR PERHAPS
PAVE THE OFFER FOR THEIR FOR
THEMSELVES THE LOOKS AT THE IF
YOU STILL. APPEAR SIR HELLO I
THANK YOU MY TRINITY FOR THE
CONTRACTORS BOARD THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION JUST SOME VERY
VERY QUICK BACKGROUND ON OUR
LICENSING STRUCTURE SO OUR
LICENSES ARE ACTUALLY ISSUED TO
THE ENTITY NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
SO WE DO ISSUE TO SOLVE
OWNERSHIPS CORPORATIONS LLCS
JOURNAL PARTNERSHIPS AND JOINT
VENTURES HOWEVER THE SOLE
OWNERSHIP ENTITY REALLY WORK
FOR ALL OF THESE ENTITIES WHAT
THAT TELLS YOU IT'S JUST. WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF OWNERSHIP THERE
IS BUT THERE'S AMPLE EVIDENCE
THAT A NUMBER OF SOLE OWNERS
HAVE- EMPLOYEES HAS BORNE OUT
IN OUR ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
ABOUT 70% OF OUR STOP WORK
ORDERS ISSUED ON ACTIVE JOB
SITES ARE TO THE SOLE OWNERS
WHO HAVE AN EXEMPTION ON FILE
AND 66% OF THE LEGAL ACTIONS-
THAT ARE TAKEN FOR A FAULT
EXEMPTION ARE TO SELL OWNERS
SO- WHILE THE BOARD IS
CERTAINLY COGNIZANT THAT THERE
MAY INDEED AND THERE LIKELY ARE
TRUE SOLE PROPRIETORSHIPS OUT
THERE WAS TRULY SOLD ONE PERSON
OPERATIONS THE EVIDENCE BEARS
OUT THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER A
LARGE NUMBER OF. SOLE OWNERSHIP
ENTITIES THAT HAVE EMPLOYEES
AND THE OWNERSHIP STRUCTURE
DOESN'T TEND TO INDICATE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WILL HAVE
EMPLOYEES I HOPE THAT ANSWERS
THE QUESTIONS IN ADVANCE- THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE LICENSES I
INDICATED TO YOU OUR TEAM.
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE
THANKS. SO I HEAR THAT THAT
THERE IS NO. EXCEPTIONS WHEN I
READ EVERY DAY EVERYBODY HAS TO
IT WHETHER A SOLE. OWNER NOT.
THANK YOU OF CENTER TO A- S.
YES THANK OU MEASURE I- WOULD
LIKE TO STAND IN SUPPORT SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTEEN WHEN I HEARD
NUMBERS THAT WOULD JUST BE
GIVEN AS TO WHAT THE LICENSING
BOARD. THE FACT THAT THAT SO
MANY EMPLOYEES THAT FEEL
CONFIDENT WHEN THEY WORK WITH
CONTRACTOR THAT THEY WILL BE
PROTECTED AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
DURING THIS PANDEMIC SO MANY
PEOPLE OF THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WORKING TO BUILD THEM IN OUR
ROADS AND WHATEVER THEY WERE
DOING- THEY WERE DOING IT WITH
A SENSE OF CONFIDENCE THAT GOD
FORBID SOMETHING HAPPENS THEIR
FAMILIES WOULD BE PROTECTED.
AND THE- INSURANCE WOULD BE
THERE FOR WORKMAN'S
COMPENSATION STATION THIS IS
JUST A SMALL FRY A FRAGMENT OF
THEIR SUPPORT AND TO FIND THAT
THERE ARE SO MANY- THAT ARE NOT
PROTECTED IF THIS IS OUR FIRST
STEP TO MAKE SURE WE EQUALIZE
IT WE LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
SO WITH THAT I URGE THE AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- CENTER ANY
MEMBERS ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE SENATOR
DODD WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SENATE BILL. TWO
SIXTEEN. MOTION MADE BY SENATOR
LEYVA. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE ON. SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTEEN TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RALPH BY RALPH HI MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE ARCHULETA AYE
OCALAN AYE BEATS. BECKER DODD
HI DONNA I. EGGMAN AYE HER TADO
FURTADO I JONES HI JONES I
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MIN. I
MILLION HI NEWMAN HI NEWMAN AYE
AYE CHU ADOBE I VENTURA BOTH I.
HI HERE AND I. TWELVE FIVE
TWELVE NOES ZERO WE WILL PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL. WELCOME US
SENATOR RUBIO SENATE BILL TWO
SIX THREE IS YOUR FIRST MEASURE
UP TODAY AND WHEN WE FINISH
WITH THIS WE WILL MOVE TO YOUR
A SECOND MEASURE AS WELL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE TODAY I
PRESENT SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
THREE WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT WILL HELP CORRECT THE
LONG HISTORY OF BIAS AGAINST
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHEN IT COMES
TO OWNING A HOME SB TWO SIXTY
THREE REPORTS REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS TO TAKE IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING AS PART OF THEIR
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS. THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE THE HOMEOWNERSHIP GAP
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERING THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE EIGHT
TWENTY TWENTY REPORT BY THE
GREEN LINE INSTITUTE FOUND THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BLACK
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE IS 35% AND
LET YOU KNOW HOMEOWNERSHIP
SEPARATE IS 42% BOTH OF THESE
RATES ARE FAR LOWER THAN
CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL OVERALL
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE. WE CAN AND
MUST DO BETTER TO END THE BIAS
THAT IS CAUSING THIS
HOMEOWNERSHIP GAP FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR THANKFULLY THERE IS
CONSENSUS ON THIS ISSUE THIS
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND
TODAY THE PHONE TO TESTIFY HAVE
ANNA BUCK THE CALIFORNIA. OF
REALTORS. THANK YOU THANK YOU A
REMINDER THAT EACH SIDE WILL
ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURES MISBACH. HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER KAREN MEMBERS OF
THE OMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANNA
BACH AND I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. AND YOU'VE HEARD THE
BILL'S AUTHOR THIS MORNING AT
THE TWO SIXTY THREE AT THE
REQUIREMENT OF IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING THROUGH THE EXISTING
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS. FOR REAL ESTATE
LICENSEES IT ALSO UPDATE THE
CURRENT FAIR HOUSING TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS TO INCLUDE
ELEMENTS SUCH AS ROLE PLAY
SCENARIOS. THAT ALLOW LICENSEES
TO WALK IN THE SHOES OF SOMEONE
EXPERIENCING HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION. LAST SESSION AB
TWO FOUR ONE. OUR BY ASSEMBLY
COME LONGER DE REQUIRE.
IMPLICIT TRAINING FOR SIR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. AB TWO
FOR TWO BY THE SAME AUTHOR
REQUIRED IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING
FOR COURT EMPLOYEES. JUDGES AND
ATTORNEYS. JUDICIAL PROCEEDINGS
AND HEALTHCARE SERVICES HAVE
THE POWER TO CHANGE THE PROJECT
TO DECORATE THE CHRISTMAS
LIGHTS. AND BIAS IN THESE AREAS
CAN HAVE THE DISTURBING THE
FACT OF UNDERMINING CONFIDENCE
IN THESE SYSTEMS. AND IT'S BEEN
LIVING THE ACTIVE A HOME. CAN
ALSO HE SAID BACK DURING THE
PRE LIFE FOR THE VAST OF.
PURCHASING A HOME IS LARGEST
AND MOST IMPORTANT FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION THEY WILL EVER
MAKE. IT HAS THE POWER TO SET A
FAMILY ON A CORD TO CREATING
FINANCIAL SECURITY AND
GENERATIONAL WELL. AS AN
ORGANIZATION WE WANT TO DO ALL
THAT WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT THIS
PROCESS IS. AS FAIR AND
EXPERIENCE FROM BY AT THE
POSSIBLE WHAT IS OF COURSE
IMPOSSIBLE TO ELIMINATE
IMPLICIT BIAS. TRAINING COURSES
GIVE PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXAMINE AND ADJUST THEIR
PATTERNS OF THINKING WITH THE
GOAL OF ELIMINATING BIAS. THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS PRICES JUST OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND. OTHER STATE
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND REAL ESTATE
LICENSEES NOT ALL OF THESE
LICENSEES ARE REALTORS BUT WE
BELIEVE ALL REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS- THE INTERACT.
WITH THE PUBLIC IN CONSUMERS-
SHOULD BENEFIT FROM THE
TRAINING AS AN ORGANIZATION WE
HAVE ALWAYS SUPPORTED
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ENHANCE
CONSUMER PROTECTION A REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTION. AND IN
RECENT TIMES WE ARE PROUD TO
SAY THAT IS ALSO INCLUDED FAIR
HOUSING INITIATIVES. IF YOU ARE
GREETED MANDELA PROFESSIONALS
THAT EVERYONE OPERATE TO THE
HIGHEST ETHICAL STANDARDS AND
THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY
ASKING FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WE
WILL HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY AND I SEE NONE. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SENATE BILL TWO SIX
THREE. I SEE NO WHAT. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW. ON THE WITNESSES
WERE. TO TESTIFY VIA TELE. OF
THIS. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TWO SIX THREE WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER TERRY
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THIS
TIME PRESS ONE ZERO. A SECURE
WITH IT APPEARS WE HAVE NO WHEN
WISHING TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME.
OKAY LET'S- YOU CAN FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS SENATE
BILL. I SEE NO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL TWO SIX THREE. I SEE NONE
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OF THIS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL TWO SIX THREE. WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL TWO SIX THREE. THIS
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO ONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK MISTER TURNER THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR LET'S GO TO THE
MEMBERS IN THE CHAMBER. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WITH
REGARD TO THIS BILL. THANKS
PRAYER I THINK THANK YOU AND US
ARE RUBIO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- AND
THE CERTAINLY VERY SUPPORTIVE
AND- APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE REALTORS I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS THAT- IS THERE
WHITE TWO HOURS- AND HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED INSTEAD OF TURN IT
IS AN OUTCOME MEASURE I THINK
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE PEOPLE DEVELOP A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF KNOWLEDGE OR AWARENESS
IS VERSUS A FIXED NUMBER OF
HOURS- FOR THE FOR THE-
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE'RE
ESTABLISHING. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUGGESTION- YOU KNOW AND I
DEFINITELY THINK THIS YEAR
APPOINTMENT IN THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. UNLIKE OTHERS YOU KNOW IT
IS A TWO HOUR REQUIREMENT BUT
IT IS ALREADY IT'S FOLDED INTO
WHAT IT'S ALREADY REQUIRED FOR
REALTORS SO WE'RE NOT ADDING
EXTRA HOURS. AND AS I HEARD
EARLIER IN. YOUR TESTIMONY YOU
KNOW WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
PEOPLE AWARE AND THERE HAVE
BEEN REALLY AGREE JUST CASES IN
WHICH- EMAIL PEOPLE OF COLOR
HAVE TRIED TO GET IT OUT. LET'S
SAY AN ASSESSMENT ON THEIR HOME
AND THE OUTCOME IS DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT WHEN THEY GET WHITE
FRIENDS TO POSE. NOW IS SELLING
A HOME I MEAN IN ONE CASE ONE
HOME WAS APPRAISED AT HALF A
MILLION. DOLLARS HIGHER. THAN
WHAT THE BLACK COUPLE HAVE
RECEIVED WHEN THEY ARE
ENCOURAGED THAT THEIR WHITE.
FRIENDS TO POSE AS THE OWNERS
AND STAGE THE HOME WITH THEIR
FAMILY PICTURES OF WHITE
FAMILIES. HALF A MILLION MORE
CELL. IT IS NECESSARY AND THE
TWO HOURS IS FOLDED INTO THIS
ALREADY REQUIRED UP HOURS OF
TRAINING. SO IT JUST IS REALLY
ABOUT MAKING PEOPLE AWARE AND-
AND I THINK IT'S A GREAT START.
AS THAT- I- EIGHT AGAIN I
SUPPOSE FULLY SUPPORT WHAT
YOU'RE TO SHE AND SIR
APPRECIATE THAT- BUILDERS OF
CELLS ARE SPONSORS THIS BILL.
HI JUST USUALLY SUGGEST PEOPLE
LOOK AT OUTCOMES VERSUS. TAKING
UP TIME TO SOMEONE COULD SPEND
TWO HOURS AND NOT REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT VERSUS SOMEONE
COULD ACTUALLY HOPEFULLY EVEN
SEE COMPETENCY SOME OTHERS AND
AT LAST TIME. AND SO WE'RE NOT
JUST TO HELP TIME BUT WITH
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH US
REALLY HAPPY WITH THE BILL TO
PROTECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CAN I SURE JUST A LITTLE BIT TO
TALK ON TO THAT AND I DO
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BUT THE THERE IS
ACTIONABLE STEPS HERE AND- I
BELIEVE AS THE WITNESS
TESTIFIED FOR HIS ROLE PLAYING
AND JUST TO REALLY. HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT IS NOT
JUST SOMETHING THAT WE HEAR A
STUDENTS TO COME YOU KNOW WE
DON'T NECESSARILY. REALLY
UNDERSTAND THIS THERE'S REAL
PLAIN SOUL WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
OUTCOMES WE HELD TOGETHER
INFORMATION AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE UNDERSTAND. WHAT WE NEED TO
CHANGE IN THE FUTURE. THANK
CENTER BACK. CONTRA THE AUTHOR
FOR BILL WERE FIGHTING IMPLICIT
BIAS AT MANY LEVELS OF OUR
CULTURE AS WAS MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING THAT WE HAVE WE
TACKLE ANOTHER AREAS BUT IT'S
ESPECIALLY. FUN HARMFUL IN THIS
AREA IN ROB'S COMMITTEES COLORS
OF MUSIC COLOR THE MOST BASIC
NEED OF A SAFE PLACE TO LIVE.
IN MY OWN DISAGREED ON A NUMBER
OF. MEETINGS RECENTLY WERE JUST
COMING TO GRIPS AYE I'VE
LEARNED A LOT. ABOUT THE
HISTORY STRUCTURE RACISM AND IN
HOUSING AND MY COMMUNITIES- AND
THE- DAMAGES INFLICTED ON
PEOPLE OF COLOR NOT ONLY THE
RED LINE BUT- IT PREVENTED FROM
LIVING IN CERTAIN
NEIGHBOURHOODS HISTORICALLY.
BUT REALLY THAT DENIES A
GENERATIONAL WEALTH THAT
HOMEOWNERSHIP. BRINGS WHICH
BROADENS THE WHICH WIDENS THE
RACIAL ECONOMIC DIVIDE IN OUR
COUNTRY SO I THINK THIS IS A
STRONG STEP FORWARD. AND. I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER JONES.
BERMAN I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL AND SIMILAR TO
SB FORTY EIGHT EARLIER I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO SET A
REALLY HIGH BAR AND SHOW SOME
RESTRAINT WHEN WERE-
INTERFERING WITH THE DIFFERENT
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS AND HOW
THEY- ESTABLISH CONTINUING
EDUCATION. I CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR- HER CONCERNS
AND THAT THE STORY THAT SHE
SHARED THAT SHE SHARED WITH ME
PERSONALLY- IN IT AND THAT IS A
TROUBLESOME STORY- YOU KNOW
MAYBE APPRAISERS WE NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT AT THEIR CONTINUING
EDUCATION PROGRAM AS WELL. I DO
BELIEVE THAT- I HAVE A VERY
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
THREE REALTOR ASSOCIATIONS IN
MY IN IN MY COUNTY IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY- THAT REPRESENT- A HUGE
NUMBER REALTORS. AND I THINK
YOU KNOW ALL THREE OF THEIR
BOARDS ARE- IT IS THERE'S A LOT
OF DIVERSITY ON ALL THREE OF
THOSE BOARDS THE- THE SPEAKER
AND SUPPORT OF THE- BILL
ACTUALLY REYES ONE OF MY
CONCERNS IS THERE'S- FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
LICENSEES. AND CALIFORNIA AND
LESS THAN HALF OF THOSE ARE
RECOGNIZED AS CAPITAL ARE
REALTORS. AND SO WE'RE
PROPOSING YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT. YOU KNOW THE PROCESS
ENTIRE SPECTRUM OF THE
INDUSTRY- AND SO THAT THAT
RAISES CONCERN FOR ME ONE OF
THE OTHER CONCERNS AND I WOULD
IF THE AUTHOR WOULD MIND
SPEAKING TO THIS- THE ROLE PLAY
COMPONENT. YOU KNOW MOST OF THE
I THINK ALL OF THE REALTOR
CONTINUE EDUCATION NOW CAN BE
DONE ONLINE THROUGH THE GRE.
AND IS THAT CREATES- A UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE OR DO A ROLE PLAY
SO IF THE SPEAKER WOULD. LIKE
TO EXPLAIN THAT I AM CURIOUS
ABOUT HOW THE ROLE PLAYED THING
WOULD WORK BUT UNFORTUNATELY I
CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. AND I KNOW THAT IT
DOES YOU KNOW IMPACT ALL THE
LICENSEES BUT- I THINK I THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE TO START I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT AND
THERE'S DOCUMENTATION SOMETIMES
WE DON'T EVEN REALIZE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT. SOMETHING THAT W CAN
WE THINK ABOUT SO I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE THAT CURRENTLY- THERE
IS A REPORT THAT CAME OUT THAT
SPEAKS TO THE HOMES. AND
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH SIMILAR
AMENITIES AND LOS ANGELES WERE
BLACK MAJORITY NEIGHBORHOODS
FOR SEVENTEEN POINT 1% LESS.
THEIR WORTH IS LESS 71% JUST
FOR BEING A BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS
IN THE BAY AREA. LOCATED IN
BLUE MUCH NEIGHBORHOOD IS
TWENTY SEVEN POINT ONE PERCENT.
LESS SO I KNOW THAT THESE ARE
NOT THINGS THAT WE TYPICALLY
THINK ABOUT IT BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE DISPARITY IN AND
OUT OF THE PROPERTY VALUE JUST
BECAUSE IT'S A MINORITY
COMMUNITY. MY MINORITY OWNED
COMMUNITY. IT IS SOMETHING THAT
IT IS IT IS REALLY MIND
BOGGLING FOR ME PERSONALLY AS A
MINORITY. FEMALE AND MISTER
JONES AP SHARE COMMENT. BUT
IT'S A CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN AND I THINK THAT JUST
HAVING THIS KNOWLEDGE DOESN'T.
HURT BUT IT DOES HELP MOVING
FORWARD AND THEN I WILL HI
WELCOME TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU
AND SEE HOW I CAN MAKE IT
BETTER I'M OPEN TO THAT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SEND A MAN. THANK YOU
SENATOR I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL- I THINK THE WHOLE POINT
OF IMPLICIT RACIAL BIAS. AND I
HAVE CONFESSED THIS IS NOT A
FIELD I'M SUPER FAMILIAR WITH
BUT I HAVE HAD COLLEAGUES IN
THE PAST WHO ARE LEADING
EXPERTS IN THIS AREA HI AND I
THINK THAT SOME OF THE ID HERE
IT'S IS THAT A SIMPLICITY IT'S
COMES FROM PEOPLE WHO. YOU KNOW
THESE ARE NOT THE KKK OR OPEN
RACISTS OF THE PASSER THERE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WE WOULD CALL
GOOD PEOPLE- THEY THEY THINK OF
THEMSELVES OF RACE NEUTRAL BUT
WE ALL HAVE RACIAL BIASES I
HAVE RACIAL BIASES EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM HAS RACIAL BIASES.
AND I THINK THE WHOLE POINT OF
AN EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT IS
TO RECOGNIZE THAT NOW MANY OF
US MAY HAVE READ THAT STORY
ABOUT. THE BLACK COUPLE IN
MARIN. AND THEN IT GOT AN
APPRAISAL FOR THEIR HOME. ARE
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS LOW AND SO
THEY WENT OUT AND GOT A WHITE
FRIEND OF THEIRS TO POSE AS THE
HOME BUYER- THAT NEXT APPRAISAL
THEY HAD WITH THE WHITE THIS
PRINCIPLES AT HOME BUYER WAS
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
GREATER. HI THIS IS ONE OF MANY
EXAMPLES IN THIS ONE WAS VERY
STARKLY DOCUMENTED I IT WAS IN
THE NEWS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. BUT IF YOU ARE
PARTICULARLY UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY YOU ARE FACING THIS
TYPE OF IMPLICIT RACIAL BIAS
THROUGHOUT YOUR LIFE AND AS
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ELOQUENTLY POINTED OUT
HOMEOWNERSHIP. IS SO IMPORTANT.
FOR BUILDING AT FOR. WEALTH AND
IT IS SO IMPORTANT AS A RESULT
THAT WE TRY TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
AND IMPLICIT RACIAL BIAS. IN
THIS REGARD AND SO I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT FIRST STEP I WOULD
ENCOURAGE ALL OF US TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE MIGHT DO GOING
FORWARD BECAUSE EDUCATION. IS
IMPORTANT BUT MAY NOT BE ENOUGH
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING
MORE ABOUT WHAT WE AS A BODY
CAN DO BECAUSE- THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT. ASPECT OF. OUR
ECONOMIC WELL BEING IN THE
STATE. SIDE SUPPORT THIS BILL
INTENDED BEFORE THANK YOU MR.
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER
ARCHULETA. YES THANK YOU MISTER.
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY THREE
WILL OBVIOUSLY OPEN THE DOOR TO
REALITY. BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IS A
PROFESSIONAL. ETHICAL
ASSOCIATION DEALING WITH-
PROFESSIONAL REAL ESTATE
AGENTS. WHO ARE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. BUT
AGAIN AS- ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
MENTIONED THERE'S FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND APPROXIMATELY
LICENSED. REAL ESTATE AGENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. BUT MAYBE
ONLY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
OUR ACTUAL REALTORS. TO THE
REALTORS ASSOCIATION ARE
CONSTANTLY GIVING CONTINUING
EDUCATION CONTINUOUS TEACHINGS
AND GUIDING- OF FAIR PRACTICES
BUT THIS BILL. ADDRESSES THE
BLANKET ACROSS THE BOARD THAT
ALL. PEOPLE WITH REAL ESTATE
LICENSE SHOULD BE AWARE OF THIS
PRESIDENT BIASES THAT THEY MAY
CONTAIN. AT THE TREAT EVERYBODY
FAIRLY GIVEN EVERYONE THE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. SO SOMEONE CAN
CROSS THE LINE AND GO TO THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE TRACKS PER SE
AND PARTICIPATE IN BETTER
SCHOOLS BETTER- EDUCATION FOR
THEIR KIDS OR BETTER SHOPPING
OR BETTER JOBS WHATEVER. AND
THAT WOULD JUST MELT TOGETHER
AS WE SHOULD AS AMERICANS IT
NOT LOOKING THAT ONE'S- SKIN
COLOR OR THEIR BACKGROUND OR
THE RELIGION OR WHATEVER. IN
WE'VE GOT TO OPEN UP THE STORE
IN THESE ADDITIONAL HOURS IF
THAT WILL HELP. BY ALL MEANS
LET'S DO IT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. IS A
SAND YES- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS TO SAY
YES AND I IS A LICENSED REAL
ESTATE BROKER AND A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF REALTORS I TO SAY
YES. SO I AGREE AS B. TWO SIXTY
THREE SHOULD BE ACCEPTED. AND I
HOLD PROBABLY HARD TO THE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR. THANK
YOU SENATOR MEMBERS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OR COMMENTS OF THE
AUTHOR. SEEING THAT. THURMOND
AS SORRY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
SIR WE HAVE. HAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT- THE APPRAISAL
OF HOMES AND THERE'S HOMES
COMING IN- THE VALUE COMING IN
LOWER THAN WHAT IT WOULD
COMMAND IF A WHITE COUPLE WERE
SHOWING THE HOME AND WHAT I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS THIS
BILL RELATES TO- REAL ESTATE
AGENTS BUT. THIS DOESN'T
COVERED THOSE WHO DO APPRAISALS
OF HOMES RATE. SO IF THAT'S-
WHAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON. IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT ADDRESSES-
WHERE IN A PART OF THAT PROBLEM
IS GENERATING FIRM. CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THEM HELLO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT AND I AND THAT
ONLY JUST INDICATES HOW
WIDESPREAD THIS THIS ISSUE AS
AND WE HAVE TO TACKLE THIS
ISSUE FROM ALL ANGLES WHEN I
SHARED SOME OF THE DATA ALREADY
HERE IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW THE
VALUE OF HOMES AND AS WE SHARED
SOMEBODY AND THERE IS A LOT OF
EXAMPLES ON THE BOOKS IN TERMS
OF REALTORS APPRAISERS. THIS IS
ONE ISSUE BUT YOU'RE RIGHT AND
I HOPE TO MOVE FORWARD IN THE
FUTURE TO TACKLE THE APPRAISER
SIDE OF THE ISSUE BYE DAD THANK
YOU FOR POINTING THAT OUT I
THINK THAT JUSTICE IN
PARTICULAR GIVEN THE HISTORICAL
AND SOCIAL IMPACTS OF THOSE
BIASES IT'S JUST INFORMATIVE
AND I THINK AS I STATED EARLIER
HE JUST HELPED EVERYONE START
THINKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND
JUST RECOGNIZING YOUR OWN
BIASES SO- I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND- THANK YOU. SERMON
I AND I THINK THAT LAST
QUESTION WAS RAISED BY ONE OF
MY COMMENTS AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO QUICKLY ADDRESS THAT.
OF COURSE THIS BILL REFERS TO
REALTORS AND NOT APPRAISERS-
BUT I GAVE THAT EXAMPLE AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE EXTENT TO WHICH
IMPLICIT BIAS- IS RAMPANT THE
REAL ESTATE TRANSACTIONS AT THE
STATE. THANK MISTER. THANK YOU
I SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- CENTER RUBIO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU
FARE AND WOULD JUST WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
COMMENTS THOSE THAT ARE
SUPPORTIVE AND THOSE THAT HAVE
QUESTIONS YOU KNOW I JUST I'M
GLAD THAT IT OPENED UP THE
CONVERSATION AND WE CAN TO
SOLVE DOES RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
IS AN ISSUE AND I'M OPEN TO
DISCUSSING IT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WHO STILL HAVE
CONCERNS AND SEE HOW WE CAN
MAKE IT BETTER. AND WITH THAT I
JUST ASKED MEMBERS HELP ME UP
LEFT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
TO HOMEOWNERSHIP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES TO BE HAVE A MOTION
ON SENATE BILL TWO SIX THREE-
MOTION BY SENATOR LEYVA. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM THREE SB TWO
SIX THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO DO
YOU PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROTH. ROTH AYE MELENDEZ.
ARCHULETA I URGE A LOT I'D BE
FIVE EIGHT FIVE BAKER RIGHT
BAKER HI EGGMAN HI EGGMAN AYE
DODD I THOUGHT I HER TADO HIGH
FURTADO HI JONES. NO JONES
NARROW. HI LEYVA I MIN BY. MAIN
HI NEW I NEWMAN AYE ACCIONES
OPEN. HI PICTURE ABOUT A GUY HI
CAN I. THE VOTE IS FIVE TWELVE
KNOWS ONE- WE'LL PUT THIS
BETTER ON CALL AS WELL. THE
RUBIO ITEM NUMBER SIX SENATE
BILL THREE TEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT SB THREE TEN AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
RELATED TO CANCER MEDICATION I
WOULD LIKE TO PROTECT THE
TERMINATE HIS STUFF FOR WORKING
SO DILIGENTLY WITH ME TEND TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD WHAT
THIS BILL DOES SB THREE TEN
WILL CREATE A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
THAT WILL ALLOW CANCER PATIENTS
TO DONATE THEIR UNUSED. ORAL
ANTICANCER MEDICATIONS TO
PATIENTS IN NEED THERE'S SO
MANY FAMILIES HAVE BEEN TOUCHED
BY CANCER INCLUDING MY OWN AND
IT'S SUCH A PERSONAL AND
DIFFICULT ISSUE TO DEAL WITH
AND THIS PROGRAM IS MODELED
AFTER OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY- MOVED FOR WITH
THESE EFFORTS. IT WILL BE
COORDINATED BY THE PRESCRIBING
PHYSICIAN AND REGULATED BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD THE BILL INCLUDES
NECESSARY PATIENT PROTECTIONS
AND SAFEGUARDS WHICH WAS
IMPORTANT TO ME THE
PARTICIPATING PHYSICIANS MUST
BE BOARD CERTIFIED IN ONCOLOGY
OR HEMATOLOGY THE DONOR MUST BE
A PATIENT OF RECORD WITH THE
PHYSICIAN. AN EXISTING
RELATIONSHIP IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO THIS PROCESS THE
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDES
OPIOIDS RAM TRUCKS AND
INJECTABLES ANY MEDICATION THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN RECYCLED IS
ALSO EXCLUDED FROM FROM THIS
PROCESS. MISTER TURN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE TWO WITNESSES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER THEIR
TESTIMONY BY PHONE ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE WE HAVE DOCTOR
DANIEL MERIDA BOARD MEMBER OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONCOLOGY AND HENNY'S
POLICE CALL TO SHARE HIS
PERSONAL FAMILY STRUGGLE THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE NEED FOR
COMMITTEES TO INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES I WOULD ASK THE
SPEAKERS TO- ATTEND TO THOSE
LIMITS. THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED. HELLO MY IS DON DANIEL.
I'VE BEEN A LONG CONTRACT FELT
FOR YEARS. STARTING AT STANFORD
YES OUT NOW AND BY PRACTICE AND
NOT CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
RUBIO AND OUR MANY COOP DONE
COMMITTEE CENTER ARCHULETA DIED
EGGMAN FURTADO. CHAMPION
CHAMPIONING THIS ISSUE ON OF
CALIFORNIA CANCER. WHEN THEY'RE
GOING. I THANK REGION ONE
PRODUCTION REVENUE YES- WITH
THE DRUG THING MADE HIM FOR A
GRAM CALIFORNIA WITHIN WHEN
PATIENTS BACK WITH THE- REDUCE
WEIGHT HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND
PROVIDE. TREATMENT UNDER POP.
THANK YOU FOR COULD SCORE
CALIFORNIA THANK MAY.
MEDICATIONS YOU DON'T FOLLOW IN
MAILING TO SIDE OF SO YOU.
FATHER MAY NEED TO BE PERFECT.
BUT HE'S ON YOUR AGO MEDICATION
ALL DID. DUE TO A LACK OF
SYSTEM REPURPOSE MEDICATIONS
FOR NEW THANK. THAT EXPECTED
STRAP WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED THIS
PROGRAM A MERRY EDUCATION
PROTECTION AS OUTLINED BY TENER
RUBIO BECAUSE WE NO PATIENT
SAFETY IS OUR OBLIGATION WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THE SAFEGUARDS TO
ENSURE WE PROTECT PATIENT WHILE
WE WORK TO ENSURE THEY CAN HAVE
HIGHLY ACTIVE THE NEED A MEDIC
NEEDED TREATMENT. A TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN FROM
RESEARCHERS THE MEMORIAL SLOAN
KETTERING TOWN THAT NEARLY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR BEING
LOST ANNUALLY IN WAIT FOR HIM
FOR DRUGS YOU TWENTY THIRD
MEDICATION REPRESENTS AN
EXPENSE FOR A PICK CALIFORNIA
PATIENTS AND WHAT THE- FOR
APPROPRIATE AND TIMELY
TREATMENT OTHER STATES WOULD
PROGRAM TEMPLATE THE BENCHMARK
THOSE FEW THOUSAND FOUR AND
FIVE. DAYS HM UNITED STATES
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS I URGE
YOU'RE A VOTE TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA PAGES WHAT CANCER
FINALLY ACTED THE NEEDY CARE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATE
RUBIO TO X. TO EXPECT ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE YES I CAN-
YEAH I'M HERE OKAY. EVERYTHING
YES WE HAVE ABOUT- I'LL GET.
I'LL GIVE YOU A MINUTE. HIS
ONLY YOU FOR A LONG TO PROVIDE
IN SB TEN BY CENTER RUBIO MY
NAME IS SPOKE ON THE SMALL
BUSINESS ON AND FATHER EACH IN
DIEGO TWO YEARS AGO MY ARE
AVAILABLE DIAGNOSE HE YEAH I
JUST ONE MONTHS OLD FORTY
MILLION ABOUT TWO AGO SHE ONLY
HAS A FEW MONTHS BEFORE
CONSIDERED AN ONE. HAVING TO
THE EXACT MEDICINES AT THE
EXACT TIME FOR THE ROUTINE
PRESCRIBED FOR BEST RESULT IS
CRITICAL FOR PATIENTS TO BE
CANCER EVERY DAY WE HAVE TO
ADMINISTER PRECISE DOSES OF
LIFESAVING CANCER MEDICATION TO
OUR DAUGHTER IN ADDITION TO
MONTHLY BUDGETS FOR CHEMO
ADMINISTERED THROUGH A MEDICAL
CORD NEAR OUR HEART AND KEYMOD
MINISTER INTO A SPINAL FLUID TO
RESPOND. THE DOCTOR STRESSED
HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS TO
ADMINISTER THE EXACT DOSE AND
FOUND THE PROTOCOL EXACTLY FOR
BEST CHANCE OF SURVIVAL YOU TOO
MUCH OR TOO LITTLE FOR MISSING
DOSES WOULD AFFECT YOUR
RECOVERY I COULDN'T IMAGINE NOT
HAVING THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
DRUG TREATMENT OR HAVING TO
DELAY TREATMENT DUE TO
UNAVAILABILITY. MY FAMILY AND
THOUSANDS OF OTHER CANCER
FAMILIES WITH SUPPORT ANY BILL
THAT PROVIDES THAT INCLUDES THE
ODDS OF A FAMILY MEMBER BEATING
CANCER PLEASE VOTE TO SUPPORT
ATHLETES REGIONAL TO BOTH OF
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. NOW WILL HEAR
FROM ANY. WE IN THE GALA I SE
NONE. LET'S CHECK TO SEE IF
THEY'RE ANY. IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
TO. AND OF BILL. TEN SEE NO.
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
URBAS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
BEGIN TO PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING. TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
THREE TEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THREE TIMES
PLEASE PRESS OF ONE BUTTON ZERO
AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE HAVE
ONE PARTICIPANT WHO WAS QUEUING
UP AT THIS MOMENT. WHICH IS TO
SPEAK JUST ANOTHER MOMENT PLACE.
WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE THIRTY
SIX. WHAT IS YOUR NUMBER BUT-
THANK YOU HELLO CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ARMONK. BY CANCER
NETWORK I'M- BECAUSE AND THREE
TEN OLYMPIC AND GO AND I WAS
QUICKLY I FOR YOUR I. BOATS
TODAY. THANK YOU. MISTER SURE
THERE'S ONE ELSE TO SPEAK AT
THIS WOULD YOU PLEASE THE LINE
MORE TIME JUST TO SURE THAT
HEARD FOR ALL WITNESSES ON
SENATE BILL. THREE TEN. AND
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN ARE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL THREE TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK. THERE IS NO ONE IS
QUEUED UP TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM
SUPPORT WITNESSES WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION. BEGIN
WITH WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. I SEE
NO WITNESSES. WELL NOW MOVES TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
OPPOSITION. TO SENATE BILL.
THREE TEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO BILL CREE TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THERAPIST
TIME. SURE THERE'S NO ONE WHO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU MISTER ROGER.
AND THANKS TO ALL THE WITNESSES
WHO DID SPEAK WILL NOT BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE CHAMBERS
AND ASK IF MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
EGGMAN. THANK YOU JUST A
COMMENTED THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
I'M GLAD TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS. WORKING IN THE END OF
LIFE THAT FIELD WITH CERTAINLY
SEE FIRSTHAND THE- STRUGGLES
PEOPLE HAVE TO PURCHASE
MEDICATIONS AWAY FROM
MEDICATION TO PAY FOR
MEDICATIONS. AND SO MANY OF
THEM BEING DISPOSED OF LIFE BY
FOLKS WHO DON'T NEED THEM
ANYMORE SO THIS IS A GOOD
COMMONSENSE SOLUTION WE NEED
THAT SYSTEM SET UP. SO IT'S
EASY FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEIR UNUSED
MEDICATIONS FOR OTHER SINCE IT
IS A GREAT BILL AND I WOULD
MAKE THE MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL WHEN IT'S- WHEN THAT TIME
IS. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATE-ROOM. AT DAVIS JACK I
WOULD TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR IN
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL THIS
IS A CREATIVE INNOVATIVE
SOLUTION TO AREAL PROBLEM FOR
FAMILIES AND SO- I WILL I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME AND IS A CO
AUTHOR AT THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MEMBERS SACRAMENTO. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO THE SENATE- THIS BILL
REMOVES BARRIERS TO LIFE SAVING
MEDICATION WHICH WE KNOW IS ONE
OF THE LARGEST ISSUES IN
MEDICINE IN THIS COUNTRY BUT I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS THE CENTRAL
ISSUE AT HAND. ASCRIPTION DRUG
PRICES THE UNITED STATES ARE
MORE THAN TWICE AS HIGH AS IN
OTHER COUNTRIES AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUG EXPENDITURES
ALONE ACCOUNT FOR SEVENTEEN
PERCENT. OF THE OVERALL COST OF
HEALTHCARE IN THE UNITED
STATES. 30% OF AMERICANS WHO
CURRENTLY HAVE PRESCRIPTION
MEDICINE SAY THEY HAVE SEEN
INCREASES IN OUT OF POCKET
COSTS. AND OBVIOUSLY THIS
FINANCIAL BURDEN IS ONLY
INTENSIFIED FOR CANCER PATIENTS
AS THE AUTHOR NOTES. ARE CANCER
PATIENTS DECLARE BANKRUPTCY AT
HIGHER RATES THAN OTHERS. AND
ARE SUBJECTED TO IT AMAZING AND
HORRENDOUS FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS-
THIS ABUSE WILL CONTINUE. UNTIL
WE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE SO THIS
IS A GREAT START I APPRECIATE
THE INGENUITY BEHIND THIS- BUT
NO ONE IN THIS COUNTRY SHOULD
GO BANKRUPT. OR FACE THE
POSSIBILITY OF DEATH BECAUSE
THEY LACK HEALTH INSURANCE AND
I THINK WE NEED TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION. HI SIR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS I INTEND TO VOTE
I'D THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU CENTER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE. THE BILL HAS BEEN- WELL
CENTER RUBIO WHICH LIKE CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER TURN THINKING
TOM MY COLLEAGUES HAVE JOINED
THE WHO HAVE JOINED ME AND AN
AUTHORSHIP AND NOT JUST ONE
ALSO- JUST SAY THAT THAT THIS
MEASURE IS VERY NARROW BUT IT'S
RELIEF WITH THE HI FOCUS ON
SAFETY AND A SOMEONE JUST CURRY
STATED IT REMOVES BARRIERS AND
IT SAVES LIVES AND TRAGICALLY
PATIENTS HAVE DIED BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THE MEDICATION OR
DO NOT GET IT IN A TIMELY
MANNER AND SO THIS PROGRAM IS
NOT NEW. IT'S BEEN TRIED IN
OTHER STATES SUCCESSFULLY AND
WE JUST WANT CALIFORNIA TO
CATCH UP IN THIS VERY IMPORTANT
STAFF AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE BILL HAS BEN MOVED BY
SENATOR EGGMAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO JUDICIARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM SIX SENATE
BILL THREE ONE ZERO BY SENATOR
RUBIO DO YOU PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE
ON. ROTH HI RALPH HI MELENDEZ.
ARCHULETA I URGE A LOT I I'D BE.
FIVE BATES AYE BAKER AYE BACKER
AYE DODD. I THOUGHT I EGGMAN
FONG EGGMAN AYE HER TADO. JONES
HI JONES I LEYVA ON LEYVA AYE
MAN. I MILLION HI NEWMAN HI
NEWMAN AYE AND SHOW A VOGUE.
HAN HI CAN I. THE VOTERS SIZE
ELEVEN KNOWS ZERO WILL PUT THAT
THE LONG CALL. THANK. OKAY.
LET'S MOVE TO- ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SENATOR DORADO. WELCOME SENATOR
DRAWS SO YOU HAVE ONE MEASURE
BEFORE US TODAY IT IS SENATE
BILL TWO NINE SEVEN. YES THEY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M PRESENTING TO NINETY SEVEN
SB TWO NINETY SEVEN WHICH WOULD
INCREASE THE PENALTIES FOR
REPEAT OFFENDERS OF OUR EIGHT
ONE ONE DIVERT LAW. JULY TWENTY
NINETEEN A PIPELINE EXPLOSION
AND MERCURE MARINA TRAGICALLY
TOOK THE LIFE OF WEIGHT
KILPATRICK LEAD CONSTRUCTION
TECHNICIAN AT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY. MR
KILPATRICK WAS AN ELEVEN YEAR
VETERAN OF THE COMPANY AND A
MEMBER OF THE TILLERY WORKERS
UNION. THE EXPLOSION WAS CAUSED
BY A SOLAR POWER CONTRACTORS
WHO FAILED TO CALL EIGHT ONE
ONE TO CHECK FOR GAS LINES
PRIOR TO DO GET ON THE
PROPERTY. AND RUPTURED THE LINE
SB ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT. SORRY
TWO NINETY SEVEN THE COMPANY OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH GAS UTILITY
WORKERS ON HOW TO IMPROVE GAS
SERVICE ACROSSTHE STATE BY
MAKING IT SFER FOR THE WORK
FORCE AND MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY CURRENTLY IF YOU'RE
GOING TO EXCAVATE AROUND THE
SUBSURFACE INSTALLATION YOU ARE
REQUIRED BY LAW TO CALL THE
EIGHT ONE ONE NOTIFICATION
CENTER TO ENSURE THAT YOU DON'T
DAMAGE SOME CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BURIED BENEATH
THE SURFACE THIS IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT PROVIDES
OUR ENERGY WATER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND SO ON.
IT IS NO SMALL THING WHEN AN
EXCAVATOR FAILS TO MAKE THIS
CALL DAMAGING SOMETHING BELOW
THE SURFACE IS NOT ONLY COSTLY
AND DISRUPTIVE BUT IT ALSO CAN
BE EXTREMELY DANGEROUS TO THE
WORKERS AND TO THE PUBLIC THE
BILL IS IN HONOR OF ONE SUCH
WORKER WHO TRAGICALLY LOST HIS
LIFE THIS STRATEGY COULD HAVE
BEEN AVOIDED HAD THE SOLAR
COMPANY FOLLOWED THE LAW MORE
SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES WILL
PUNISH THE BAD ACTORS AND
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE SOME
INCENTIVE FOR OTHERS TO SIMPLY
CALL EIGHT ONE ONE WE ARE HAPPY
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS%
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS-
MISTER CHAIR I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY.
KAUFMAN IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UTILITY WORKERS UNION LOCAL ONE
THIRTY TWO AND SHANE GUSMAN HIS
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN ROB
AND SEE HOW MANY MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS ERIC HOFFMAN AND I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF U. W. A LOCAL
ONE THIRTY TWO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. REPRESENTING NEARLY
FOUR THOUSAND WORKERS AT SO CAL
GAS AND I ALSO SERVED THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR. I'M
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY URGING
YOUR UNWAVERING SUPPORT AND
COMMITMENT TO ESTEEM TO NINETY
SEVEN DORADO. THE WAY
KILPATRICK GAS SAFETY ACT. ON
JULY FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE LOST OUR FALLEN
BROTHER WAKE UP PATRICK DO DO.
AN UNNECESSARY WORKPLACE
INCIDENT IN WHICH A LICENSE
CONTRACTOR WHO KNEW THE RULES
OF AB ONE ONE BIG ALERT LAWS.
PREFERRED TO BREAK THE LAW IN
THE NAME OF GETTING A JOB DONE
FASTER WHICH ULTIMATELY LED TO
OUR UNION BROTHER WAY
KILPATRICK SACRIFICING HIS
LIFE. IN AN EFFORT. TO HELP
KEEPING HIS COMMUNITY SAFE. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL IS
NOT IN AND- AS- ON. RED TAPE OR
BUREAUCRACY TO AN EXISTING LAW.
BUT RATHER THIS BILL PROVIDES
CONSENSUAL ADDITIONAL LAYER OF
WORKPLACE SAFETY BY PREVENTING
BAD STATE CONTRACTORS FROM
KNOWINGLY COMMITTING GROSS
NEGLIGENCE. BECAUSE WITHOUT
THIS BILL QUITE FRANKLY THE
STAKES ARE HIGH ENOUGH FOR
THEM. AND THEY ARE HIGH ENOUGH
FOR US AND I BESEECH YOU ALL TO
GIVE THIS BILL. THE
CONSIDERATION THAT WE DON'T
PATRICK AND HIS FAMILY
DESERVES. THIS BILL IS FOR
BURKE IMPROVED WORKER SAFETY.
FEWER OCCURRENCES FOR PEOPLE TO
GET HURT. AND REDUCTIONS IN
UNNECESSARY VENTED METHANE
EMISSIONS DUE TO DICKENS AND
BROKEN GAS LINES. AND WE KILL
PATRICK AND HIS FAMILY AND ALL
OF HIS UNION BROTHERS AND
SISTERS AT THE CHILLY WORKERS
UNION OF AMERICA OR WHO THIS
BILL IS FOR. I THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
FOR THIS LEGISLATION. I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK OUR AUTHOR
SENATOR MARLON AT THE RATE OF
FOUR INCREDIBLE AND INSPIRING
LEADERSHIP. AND TO ALL THOSE
WHO HAVE PLAYED SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL AND WITH THAT IN
CLOSING I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
WOMEN OUT THERE A VERY HAPPY
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER.
THERE MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMISSION GUSTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE UTILITY WORKERS
UNION OF AMERICA. LOCALS
REPRESENTING GAS WORKERS ACROSS
SOUTHERN PART OF OUR STATE.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT WORKPLACE
SAFETY AND PUBLIC SAFETY AS
YOU'VE HEARD WHEN A CONTRACTOR
FAILS TO CALL THE DIG ALERT
SYSTEM THEY CAN BE VERY VERY
DANGEROUS. LIVES ARE LITERALLY
AT STAKE IS OUR HOPE THAT
CREATING A HIGHER PENALTY FOR
THE TRULY BAD ACTORS OUT THERE
WILL PROVIDE A POWERFUL ENOUGH
INCENTIVE. FOR OTHERS TO FOLLOW
THE LAW. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
SOME TECHNICAL CONCERNS THAT WE
ALSO AND WE ALSO THINK THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY FOR
CONTINUING WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE DIALOGUE WITH US. ABOUT
THIS IMPORTANT LAW WE COMMIT TO
CONTINUE TO DO SO AS THIS BILL
MOVES ALONG- WE URGE YOUR
APPLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
WE ILL NOW HEAR FROM ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO. SUCH
WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHICH TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT. OF
SENATE BILL TWO NINE SEVEN. I
SEE NO WITNESSES. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SPENT SENATE BILL TWO NINE
SEVEN WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. THIS YEAR
WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE PERSON
QUEUING UP WISHING TO SPEAK
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM LINE. THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ISRAEL
SALAS WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS COMPANY AND SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB TWO NINETY SEVEN EVERY
SIX MINUTES AN UNDERGROUND
UTILITY LINE SOMEWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY IS DAMAGED BECAUSE
SOMEONE DID NOT CALL EIGHT ONE
ONE THE NATIONAL CALL BEFORE
YOU DIG PHONE NUMBER. AS THE
SENATOR STATED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REMINDED AT THE
CATASTROPHIC AND EVEN FATAL
CONSEQUENCES OF NOT CONTACTING
EIGHT ONE ONE BEFORE DIGGING
WEEK BURGER SUPPORT TODAY
ESSENTIAL TO NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THANK NEXT. THIS
TEACHER NO ONE ELSE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS
TIME THIS MODERATE WOULD YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE
TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES REGARDING SENATE BILL.
TWO NINE SEVEN. ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO
WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. HAVING
HEARD FROM SUPPORT WITNESSES WE
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. WE'LL BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY AND I
SEE NONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL TWO
NINE SEVEN. NO WITNESSES. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SERVICE IF
ANY MISSED MODERATOR WHICH YOU
PROMPT. INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL. TWO NINE SEVEN AND WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR AND THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES WHO DID SPEAK LET'S
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE CHAMBERS NOW. QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. FROM MEMBERS CENTER
ARCH LOW. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
TO SHARE I'D LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR WHAT A
GREAT BILL SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY SEVEN LIFESAVER A
LIFESAVER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MEN AND WOMEN. TODAY IN THIS
MONTH WERE HONORING WOMEN BUT
MORE WOMEN COMING INTO THE
FIELD OF CONSTRUCTION THEY TOO
MUST BE RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR-
DILIGENCE IN SERVING AND
REPRESENTING THEIR FAMILIES.
BUT THIS IS THE BILL THAT
REPRESENTS FAMILY SAVES LIVES
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT A
PRECAUTION SIMPLE EIGHT ONE ONE
A SIMPLE CALL THE GAS COMPANY
IS ON BOARD. CONTRACTORS WITH
GOOD ETHICAL TRAINING WITH
THEIR STAFF AND SOMEONE THEY'RE
ON BOARD BUT OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE WHO DON'T.
AND THIS IS THE RESULT SO THE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES THE
ADDITIONAL AWARENESS OF THIS
BILL IS MANDATORY I THINK
ACROSS THE STATE THE SAVE LIVES
AND I THINK THAT IT'S THE RIGHT
TIME. TO ACKNOWLEDGE ONCE AGAIN
ARE WORKING FORCE BETTER AFTER
THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND- GOD
BLESS FOR THE WORK THEY DO SO I
ONCE AGAIN ASK FOR THE SUPPORT
THE SENATE BILL TWO NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR COLLEAGUES ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE SANTA OTHER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION ON
SENATE BILL TUNE CENTER LEYVA
HAS MOVED. THE BILL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
EXCELLENT ALMOST TIME PLEASE
MAKE SURE TO HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE ON FILE ITEM FIVE
SENATE BILL TWO NINE SEVEN BY
SENATOR DORADO HE PASSES
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. RALPH BY RALPH I
MELENDEZ. ARCHULETA HI RACHEL
LET IBEATS. BAKER HI. BAKER AYE
DODD HI DODD AYE EGGMAN WHY
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO HIGH
FURTADO I JONES HI. JONES I
LEYVA HI LEAVE A AYE MIN FIVE
MILLION HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE
AYE CHAU ABODE. I A SHOW ABOUT
A GUY PAYER BY CAN I.
POLITICIZE TWELVE KNOWS ZERO
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MEMBERS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
ITEM NUMBER FOR SENATE BILL.
TWO EIGHT FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR- AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BE IN A PRISON TODAY HOPE ALL
MEMBERS HAD A GOOD WEEKEND- AND
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
YOU IN YOUR CREDIBLE STAFF ON
THIS BILL MISTER CHAIR ON
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY FIVE.
MISTER CHAIR CALIFORNIA'S
TRAVEL AND HOSPITALITY SECTOR
IS ONE OF THE LARGEST ECONOMIC
DRIVERS FOR THE ENTIRE GOLDEN
STATE BEFORE THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC HIT MORE THAN ONE
POINT TWO MILLION CALIFORNIANS
EARN THEIR LIVELIHOODS INTEREST
IN TRAVEL AND TOURISM RELATED
HOSPITALITY BUSINESSES VISITORS
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SPENT
A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE BILLION IN
CALIFORNIA GENERATING ABOUT
TWELVE POINT THREE BILLION IN
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES THAT WAS
A TENTH. CONSECUTIVE INCREASE
IN A ROW OF GROWTH THOUSANDS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES ALSO RELY ON A
HEALTHY HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY
FOR THEIR LIVELIHOODS NOW THE
IMPACT OF KOBE DO HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING FOR
TRAVEL AND HOSPITALITY WORKERS
IN THE THOUSANDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO RELY ON A
HEALTHY TOURISM ECONOMY THE
ECONOMIC FALLOUT OF THE
PANDEMIC IS TEN TIMES WORSE.
WORSE FOR CALIFORNIANS TRAVEL
INDUSTRY THEN THE TERRORIST
ATTACKS ON NINE ELEVEN NEARLY
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITALITY WORKERS SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
IN THE STATE HAS LOST EIGHTY
FIVE BILLION IN VISITOR
SPENDING THAT'S DOWN ABOUT 60%
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. IN
FACT TRAVEL AND HOSPITALITY
WORKERS AND WORKERS MEMBERS
MAKE UP ABOUT A THIRD OF ALL
THOSE WHO REMAIN ON
UNEMPLOYMENT THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES ARE REELING AND ONE
OF THE STATE'S MOST VITAL TAX
SOURCES HAVE DRIED UP IN FACT
IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONE SIX
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
TAX REVENUES WERE LOST. THAT
FUND VITAL SERVICES LIKE POLICE
FIRE AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY FOR LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS. IN WITHOUT HELP
CALIFORNIA'S TRY HOUSE INDUSTRY
WILL NOT RECOVER ANOTHER FOUR
TO FIVE YEARS THE GOOD NEWS THE
GOLDEN STATE IT'S WELL
POSITIONED TO REBOUND WE'RE THE
ONLY STATE IN THE NATION AS A
PRIVATELY FUNDED. TERRORISM
BUREAU. OVER THE PAST FIFTEEN
YEARS THOSE PRIVATE TOURISM
BUSINESSES HAVE INVESTED ONE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
ADVERTISING THE CALIFORNIA
BRANCH. THIS IS WHY WE ARE
ADVANCING- IN IS A BIPARTISAN
MEASURE MEMBERS FOR ADVANCING
SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE BASIC CALIFORNIA WITH A
ONE TIME FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FIND IN IN STATE AND
WESTERN MARKETS- INITIATIVE
THAT WOULD DELIVER. TEN POINT
THREE BILLION IN REVENUE TO
CALIFORNIA IN ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL STATE AND LOCAL TAX
REVENUE. NOW THIS CAMPAIGN
MEMBERS IT WAS LAUNCHED- WITH
THIS CAMPAIGN WOULD BE LAUNCHED
WIN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE CLEAR TO
APPROPRIATE AND SAFE TO BE ABLE
TO RESUME TRAVEL. THE FINAL
THING OF SAY MISTER CHAIR IS
THIS. THIS FUNDING APPROACH
THIS STRATEGY IT'S BASED OFF OF
PREVIOUS SUCCESS A AN
INITIATIVE THAT WAS DEPLOYED BY
THEN GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE TERRORIST
ATTACKS IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
CITY CALIFORNIA INVESTED A ONE
TIME EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
TO BE ABLE TO GET FOLKS
TRAVELING AGAIN. THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION RADIO
AND TELEVISION STATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE MATCH THE PUBLIC
DOLLAR ITH ANOTHER BLOCK. THAT
MEANS ARE EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION TURNING TO TWENTY
MILLION. TRAVEL JUMPED BY 10%
CALIFORNIA WAS ONE OF ONLY
THREE STATES IN AMERICA TO GROW
THEIR TOURISM MARKET. GENERATED
THREE POINT TWO BILLION IN
VISITOR SPENDING TEN POINT SIX
MILLION IN NEW LOCAL AND STATE
TAXES. WE KNOW IT WILL WORK. IN
THE INDUSTRY DESPERATELY NEEDS
OUR HELP NOW. THE BILL
SUPPORTED BY A BIPARTISAN
COALITION OF LABOR INCLUDING
THE TEAMSTERS BUSINESS THE
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS AND
NEWSPAPERS ASSOCIATION WHICH BY
THE WAY HAVE ALREADY AGREED TO
MATCH EVERY DOLLAR WITH ANOTHER
DOLLAR. IN ADVERTISING ALONG
WITH THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY
I'M GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SHANE GUSMAN WITH US TODAY FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL. AS WELL AS THE
MILLIONS THE MONEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
AND YOU WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO AMELIA AND THE ENTIRE GROUP
AT CAL TRAVEL FOR ALL THEIR
WORK. WITH THE KERR WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IBM.
THANK YOU SENATOR WITNESSES
PLEASE PROCEED. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
INVESTMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THE TEAMSTER MEMBERS
OF WORK IN ALMOST EVERY FACET
OF THE TRAVEL AND TOURISM
INDUSTRY AIRLINES RENTAL CARS
HOTELS CONVENTION CENTERS. YOUR
NAME IF YOU'RE TRAVELING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S A
GOOD CHANCE S A TEAMSTER
HELPING YOU ALONG THE WAY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PANDEMIC HAS
HAD A HUGE TOLL ON THOSE
MEMBERS. MANY OF THEIR
WORKPLACES HAVE HAD LAYOFFS
FURLOUGHS FOR COMPLETE SHUT
DOWNS. THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN
SOME SECTORS IT IS ALMOST 90%
THE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES
CANNOTBE OVERSTATED PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING AND ANXIOUS TO GO
BACK TO WORK. WE NEED TO GIVE
THE TOURISM INDUSTRY AND JUMP
START MUCH LIKE WE HAVE. AFTER
OTHER DISASTERS AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED. SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE
WILL CERTAINLY. BE A BIG HELP.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD MORNING SHARED MEMORY
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
EUROPEAN STAFF FOR ADVANCING
THE SHOPPERS MY NAME IS A
MILLION THE MONEY AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION. WITH ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING THE
TRAVEL AND TOURISM INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF EACH WEEK FIVE.
TRAVELING HE DID WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO PROTECT AND ENSURE A
THRIVING TRAVEL AND TOURISM
INDUSTRY WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
WHAT ARE DISTINCT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA. PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET WITH A HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY BUT
BECAUSE THEY ARE FUNDED ON
TOURISM BUSINESSES REVENUE ONE
TRAVEL STOPPED. SO DID THEIR
FUNDING. ALL FOR HAS CONSERVE
CASH FOR. CAN'T BUT THEIR
MARKETING WITH THIS. AS THERE
IS WINDOW. I WAS SENATOR. COULD
HAVE BEEN ESPECIALLY ON. CAL
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
WITH THE COUNTRY'S TRADE
ECONOMY. IT'S NOT AMONG THE
WORK PERFORMING. ONLY FIVE.
HAVE LOST MORE. BY WITH TWENTY.
GETTING TRAVELING WILL ANY OUR
BUSINESS TO REOPEN. GET WORKERS
BACK TO THEIR JOB AND ALL. HELP
THE ECONOMY RECOVER THAT. WITH
THE CALIFORNIA. TO THEY ARE
ONCE. AS A SENATOR. IT WAS
AFTER MY ELEVEN AND IT WORKED.
IF GIVEN AN ALLOCATION IN A
GOING TO THE- THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CAN GENERATE TEN
POINT BILLION. AND RATHER TO
CAL BUSINESSES. AND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BY MILLION AN
ADDITIONAL STATE AND LOCAL.
REVENUE FOR THESE REASONS WE
ORDERS. SB THREE FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR DO YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES ONLINE. I DO NOT
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW HEAR FOR ANY SUPPORT
WE IN THE GAL AND I SEE NO
WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY FIVE.
I SEE NO WITNESSES WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE BEGIN TO PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY FIVE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT AT THIS TIME
SPEAKING SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE WILL NOW GO
TO LINE. SIXTY FOUR. DON'T MISS
JORDAN MEMBERS COMMITTED
MORNING OKAY REQUIRED
EXTRADITION THE BILL THIS IS A
BRUTAL TRICKLE. AND LUNCH FOR
AMERICAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT. BLIND SIXTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS JULIE NON ALCOHOL- TO
DEFINE IT AND OF THE K. HOTEL
AND NOT A LOT NOT THE
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT. WINE. FORTY TWO. PINE
FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE. FIFTY ONE.
AARON CAREER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRACTION FROM PARKS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. FINE. SIXTY EIGHT.
SHE CAMERA MEMBERS MIKE DILLON
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA SKI
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. LINE. FORTY TWO. JERRY
MEMBERS SPREAD MAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE TRI COUNTY CHAMBER
ALLIANCE REPRESENTING CHAMBERS
OF COMMERCE AND VENTURA SANTA
BARBARA AND SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. LINE. SIXTY
SEVEN. MORE LITERATURE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF THIS IS
BRITNEY OUR STUDY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NEW PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ARE DRY THAT YOU
THANK YOU THANK GOODNESS. SURE
NO ONE ELSE IS BUT THEY WISH
SPEAK THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORT WITNESSES REGARDING
THIS BILL. AND AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO WISH TO
SPEAK PLEASE SIGNAL BY PRESSING
ONE NINE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THERE IS NO
ANY KID WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM SUPPORT WITNESSES WE
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION. LET'S BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY AND I
SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES.
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY FIVE AND I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES THERE EITHER. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING OF ISTHMUS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
BEGIN TO PROP THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY FIVE WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THOSE WITNESSES. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO BILL TWO
EIGHTY FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THE ZERO TOLERANCE. MISTER
CAREY NO ONE IS SIGNALED THE
STATE THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WE
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
REGARDING THIS BILL. CINNAMON
YEAH I JUST WANTED TO- STAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL I CALIFORNIA IS
pBLESSED WITH SO MANY BEAUTIFUL
AND FUN THINGS TO SEE AND DO
INCLUDING IN MY HOME DISTRICT
IN ORANGE COUNTY- I WOULD
EMPHASIZE THAT I THINK EQUITY
IS IMPORTANT AND I AM NOT SURE
WHAT THE MECHANISMS WILL BE SO
THIS IS A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR OF IT- HOW WILL THE
MONEY BE ALLOCATED TO ENSURE
THAT ALL GEOGRAPHIC AREAS ARE
REPRESENTED EQUALLY. MORE
APPROPRIATELY. IS IT OKAY
MISTER CHAIR AT THREE YOU TO BE
AN ANSWER. YES SIR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- SENATOR ADMIN INTAKE
YOU MISTER CHAIR. GREAT
QUESTION SO THERE IS GOING TO
BE AN INITIATIVE CALLED CALLING
ALL CALIFORNIANS THAT THERE'LL
BE THREE DIFFERENT FLIGHTS OF
THIS CAMPAIGN THAT WILL BE
ADVANCE THE FIRST FLIGHT WILL
BE FOCUSED ON DESTINATION IN
STATE MARKETS THERE'LL BE
SEVERAL SPOTS PRINT ADS ONLINE
ADS FOCUS ON SOUTHERN
pZERO ONE COUNTRY- AND THEN
GOING UP TO THE NORTH COAST SO
IT THERE IS GOING TO BE
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY THAT WOULD
BE ADVANCE VIA VISIT
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION THERE
WILL BE AN AD HOC. WORKING
GROUP THAT WILL BE ESTABLISH
WITH REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
TOURISM INDUSTRY FROM ALL.
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. THEY WILL
BE THE ONES THAT WILL BE
RECOMMENDING HOW THOSE DOLLARS
WILL BE SPENT. EQUITABLE ACROSS
THE STATE. TO THE FULL BUSY
CALIFORNIA BOARD.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THEME
PARKS TOURISM BUREAUS LABOR
WILL ALL BE PART OF THIS
WORKING GROUP THAT WILL ADVANCE
THOSE FINAL RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU MUCH FOR BY THAT'S
THE EXCELLENT ANSWER AND I
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK THAT
WENT INTO THIS HI IT SOUNDS TO
ME LIKE THIS BILL WILL MORE
THAN PAY FOR ITSELF MANY TIMES
OVER WITH THE ADDITIONAL
ECONOMIC REVENUE THAT- TO
CREATE AND SO I. WOULD ASK TO
BE A CO AUTHOR SOON AS
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER MEN AND I WOULD JUST ADD
TO IT MISTER OFF AT YOUR ROTH-
THAT- SENATOR DODD. CENTER
MELINDA INCIDENT HER TITLE JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU. THEIR
THEY'RE ALSO CO AUTHORS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER MAN
OUT FOR THAT- THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK TOGETHER SIR. THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD YOU MIGHT IS A-
THIS. AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE IS
THE CENTER. I JUST LIKE TO FOR
THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS. FOR
THIS IS A SECTOR OF OUR ECONOMY
THAT WE'VE FORGOTTEN A LOT
ABOUT. WE TALK ABOUT
RESTAURANTS ALL THE TIME WOULD
BE. AND THEY HAVE THEY BEEN
DECIMATED. BUT THIS INDUSTRY
REALLY IS TAKING A BIG HIT- I
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU SIR
COLLEAGUES ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SENATOR. MELINDA'S
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FOR IN
LINE MAY BE TO BE A CO AUTHOR-
AND CENTER AND I CAN MAKE A%
VERY GOOD POINT WHAT I MEAN ALL
OF US ARE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
SECTORS HAVE BEEN HARD HIT BY
THIS NOT JUST THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY NINE NOW IN THE
EASTERN PART OF MY DISTRICT ON
THE KATELLA VALLEY AREA WHERE
THEY DON'T RELY HEAVILY ON
TOURISM I MEAN THEY REALLY HAVE
BEEN DECIMATED- AND THIS IS.
NOT IT'S NOT GOING TO FIX
EVERYTHING BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
GOING TO HELP TREMENDOUSLY AND
I THINK WE OWE IT TO EVERYONE
TO PUT THIS MONEY FOR IT IN A
WAY THAT CAN BRING THEM BACK TO
LIFE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU CENTER CENTER JONES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
CINNAMON WHERE I DO ALSO I
THINK THE BILLS GET DELIVERED-
REQUEST TO BE ADDED ON THE
QUOTE THERE'S WELL. BE HONORED
IN DECEMBER CENTER PRETTY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. SIR FOR. YES
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN TO THE
AUTHOR WITH A GREAT
PRESENTATION- I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT IN MY DISTRICT.
WE HAVE NOTS BERRY FARM. DOWN
THE ROAD WE'VE GOT DISNEYLAND.
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN AFFECTED.
AND THIS BILL WILL OPEN UP THE
DOORS. TO ADVERTISING NOT ONLY
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS THE STATE. AND I THINK
IT'S STORAGE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I WOULD LOVE TO
BE A CO AUTHOR AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SIR
BATES. THANK YOU I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ADD MY I THINK USED TO-
THE GOOD SENATOR MCGUIRE FOR-
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. MY
DISTRICT ARE ORANGE COUNTY
SOUTH RUNS THE ENTIRE COAST
DOWN TO ANTHONY THIS HUGE
TOURISM- AREA SO I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR WELL
WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENTS
ITSELF AND AGAIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR CHAU.
I WOULD JUST. JUST LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL
THINK IT'S GREAT. HELP AND AS-
MY FELLOW COLLEAGUE MELINDA
STATED IT'S A START AND- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEE IT GO
THROUGH AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE.
ACCEPTED AS A CO AUTHOR AS WELL
THE CASE. THANK YOU CENTER LAST
CALL FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE CENTER MCGUIRE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOW
ME TO PRESENT THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US THANK YOU TO
YOUR INCREDIBLE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US AS WELL I JUST
WANT TO SAY HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE
TO SENATOR MAINE SENATOR
ARCHULETA SENATOR JOHN SENATOR
BATES AIN'T CENTER ARE TROUBLED
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO BE TO
WORK WITH US ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. EVERY CORNER OF THE
STATE. TOURISM INDUSTRY HAS
CRATERED CRATER- INBIG CITIES
AND IN SMALL TOWNS AND WHAT WE
KNOW WHEN WE INVEST IN TOURISM
AND HOSPITALITY WE WILL SEE
THAT RETURN SIGNIFICANTLY NOT
JUST N OUR ECONOMY BUT FOR OUR
LOCAL TAX BASE AND THE OTHER
CRITICAL PIECE ALL IN WITH THIS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE SPEND
WE HAVE A COMMITMENT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS THAT
DON'T MATCH OUR STATE DOLLARS
WITH ANOTHER BOOK THIS FORTY
FIVE MILLION TURNS INTO NEARLY
TWO. HUNDRED MILLION IN
ADVERTISING- TO BE ABLE TO GET
FOLKS TRAVELING SAFELY AGAIN
FOR THE GOVERNOR APARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH ALLOWS US TO DO
SO WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I DON'T THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DODD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE
HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE ON FILE
ITEM FOR SENATE BILL TWO EIGHT
FIVE MAGUIRE'S. THE PAST RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH HI. ROTH HI
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE ARCHULETA
AYE ARCHULETA AYE BEATS HI
BEATS HI BECKER DAUGHTER HI
DODD AYE EGGMAN HI EGGMAN AYE
HER TADO HI HER TADO AYE JONES.
JONES I LEYVA HI LEAVE A AYE
MIN AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NEWMAN AYE AYE CHAU ABODE I
VENTURA BURKE IPN. HI CAN I.
VOTERS HIS. KNOWS WE'LL PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL. SEARCH A
LETTER ITEMS SEVEN AND NINE
ITEM SEVEN IS SENATE BILL THREE
SEVEN SEVEN WE WILL START WITH
THAT ONE AND THEN WE WILL MOVE
TO SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHT FOUR
SO ITEM SEVEN SENATE BILL THREE
SEVEN SEVEN CENTER JEWELERS.
THANK YOU A GERMAN ROTH AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN RADIOLOGIST
ASSISTANT. TITLE PROTECTION. A
PRACTICE ACTS PROVIDES THE
LICENSURE THE REGULATION OF
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS BY
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
EXISTING LAW ALSO PROVIDES FOR
THE CERTIFICATION AND
REGULATION OF RADIOLOGICAL
TECHNOLOGIST BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE RADIO OFF THE
RADIOLOGIC ASSOCIATES THIS IS A
SYSTEM RATHER THE PROFESSION
ITSELF. BOB WAS CREATED TO MEET
NEEDS FOR ADVANCED PRACTICE OF
RADIO RADIOLOGICAL GRAPH FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF RADIOLOGY THE
AMERICAN REGISTRY OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNICIANS. THE SOCIETY OF
RADIOLOGISTS AND TECHNOLOGISTS-
THEY ALL AGREE. RADIOLOGIST
ASSISTANT COMPLETE ADVANCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING WITH A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
CURRICULUM AND RADIOLOGIST
DIRECT CLINICAL- PERCEPTOR
SHIP. RADIOLOGIST ASSISTANTS
ARE REQUIRED TO WORK AT LEAST
ONE YEAR AS A RADIOLOGIST-
GRAPHIC TO BE TO QUALIFY FOR
THE RADIOLOGIST SYSTEM
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
RADIOLOGIST ASSISTANT DID NOT
DIAGNOSE PATIENTS PRESCRIBED
MEDICATION OR THERAPY. TO ENTER
OR INTERPRET IMAGES AND ALWAYS
WORK UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF
RATE OF A RADIOLOGIST HOWEVER.
OTHER THAN RADIOLOGISTS NO
OTHER PRACTITIONER GETS AS MUCH
SPECIALIZED TRAINING IN
RADIOLOGY SERVICES AND
RADIATION SAFETY AS A
RADIOLOGIST ASSISTANT. TODAY
THIRTY ONE STATE LICENSE EXCEPT
WHERE OTHERWISE RECOGNIZE
RADIOLOGIST ASSISTANTS AS A
PROFESSION. THE VETERANS HEALTH
ADMINISTRATION WILL BE ISSUING
QUALIFICATION STANDARDS TO
INCLUDE RADIOLOGIST SYSTEMS AS
A PROVIDER IN RADIOLOGY
DEPARTMENTS IN OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED OF THE NATION'S
VETERANS AFFAIRS MEDICAL
CENTERS. FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
STATE GOVERNMENTS AGREE THAT
RADIOLOGISTS AND GREATLY
INCREASES HOSPITAL EFFICIENCY
AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO PATIENT
CARE ALL Y. PROVIDED THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF RADIATION
SAFETY. RADIOLOGIST ASSISTANT
EXTEND THE REACH OF THE
RADIOLOGIST AND FREE THEM TO
FOCUS ON THEIR SERVICES ONLY A
RADIOLOGIST CAN PROVIDE SUCH AS
PERFORMING COMPLEX PROCEDURES
INTERPRETING IMAGES GENERALLY
DIAGNOSING AND TREATING
PATIENTS. WITH THIS BILL
CALIFORNIA WILL RECOGNIZE THE
PROFESSION OF THE RADIOLOGIST
ASSISTANT AND PROTECT AND
CREATE THE TITLE RADIOLOGIST
ASSISTANT. SB THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE WOULD
RECOGNIZE RADIOLOGIST SYSTEM TO
CALIFORNIA AT MAKE IT UNLAWFUL
FOR ANY PERSON TO CALL THEM
STAGE CALL THEMSELVES A
RADIOLOGIST SYSTEM OR TO USE
SPECIFIED TERMS TO IMPLY OR
SUGGEST THAT A PERSON IS A
RADIOLOGIST ASSISTANT. UNLESS
THAT PERSON FULFILLS THE
REQUIREMENTS AS STATED IN LAW.
FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
PLEASE I HAVE MET HELL- MET
HEALTH- REPRESENTING THE BILL
SPONSORED THE AMERICAN REGISTRY
OF RADIOLOGIST TECHNOLOGIST-
AND I'VE ALSO HAVE BOB ACKERMAN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
RADIOLOGICAL SOCIETY. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- MY COLLEAGUES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU CENTER LET'S
MOVE TO THE TESTIMONY FROM
YOUR- LEAD. A SUPPORT WITNESSES
SO HOPEFULLY THEY WILL STAY ON
THE LINE TO THE POINT WHERE WE
HAVE MEMBER. QUESTIONS BECAUSE
THERE MAY BE SOME. SO FIRST TO
SUPPORT WITNESS PLEASE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN. MY NAME IS TERRY
MCHALE WITH IRON MAIDEN
ASSOCIATES. REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN REGISTRY OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS. SENATOR ACKERMAN
AT THE MONEY WILL MAKE YOU CAN
COMMUNICATE THIS WITHIN THE
THREE MINUTES SAYS WERE
REQUIRED. MORE THAN THREE
DECADES AGO THE MILITARY
REALIZED THAT THE LIMITED
NUMBER OF TECH BRADY OLOGY IN
THEIR RANKS. A BETTER SERVED BY
QUALITY TRAINED AND EDUCATED
CATEGORY OF RADIOLOGISTS AND-
IT WORK AND IT WORKED WELL
THIRTY MORE THAN THIRTY STATES
NOW RECOGNIZE RADIOLOGIST
ASSISTANTS THIS BILL PROVIDES
TITLE PROTECTION IN CALIFORNIA.
THE LEGISLATION IS VERY
SPECIFIC THAT THE ASSISTANT
WILL WORK ONLY UNDER THE
DIRECTION OF A SUPERVISING
RADIOLOGIST. WE ARE PLEASED
THAT THE RADIOLOGIST THEMSELVES
CO SPONSORING THIS BILL. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW RADIOLOGISTS TO
WORK MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFICACIOUSLY AND ALLOW OUR AGE
TO WORK MORE FULLY. TO THEIR
SKILL THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. A FEW
THE NEXT. STRUGGLING YES. IF
YOU WISH TO SPELL I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF BOB ACKERMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE- CALIFORNIA A LOT- CITING
THE INTERRUPTION THIS IS A IN
THE MODERATOR SPEAKER UP PLEASE
TURN OFF SPEAKER. THANK YOU YES.
OKAY SORT OF BOB BAKKEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RADIOLOGICAL SOCIETY WHAT PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR SB THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN. WE'RE DEALING ASSISTANCE
HAVE BEE RECOGNIZED THE
VALUABLE POSITION EXTENDER
RADIOLOGIST. TOOL TO ADDRESS
GROWING RADIOLOGY REPORTS
DISHES. BUT A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE BETWEEN AMERICA
CULTURALLY ALLEGING AND THE S.
R. T. TO DESIGN THE ARE A
EXTENDER PROGRAM. PROVIDES A
CAREER PATH FOR RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS TO ADVANCE THEIR
PROFESSION AND WHAT IS A DANCE
TRAINING- IT ALLOWS THE R.
EIGHT. TO ASSIST RADIOLOGISTS
IN THE DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING
SETTING. THEY ARE UNDER DIRECT
SUPERVISION THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
PERFORM PATIENT ASSESSMENT. FOR
MANAGEMENT SELECTED QUALITY
IMAGING PROCEDURES. SENATE
ARCHULETA INDICATED THAT YOU'RE
NOT HER. FOR MANY FINAL. SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU SIR. WE WILL NOW FROM ANY
SUPPORT WHO IN THE GALA AND I
KNOWS WITNESS ARE ANY WHAT AND
ONE TWO WE TO TEST. IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL THREE SEVEN
SEVEN I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES
LET'S NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELEPHONE OR TELECONFERENCING
SERVICE- MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PEASE BEGIN TO PROMPT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THREE
SEVEN SEVEN WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. SO MANY NEEDS TO
TURN THEIR MUTE ON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND AGAIN MISTER
CARRIE APOLOGIZE YOUR WITH THE
SPEAKER ON WITH ALL PLEASE USE
YOUR KEY BUTTON. THANK YOU AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE IS AS THEY KNOW THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR. BUT SNELL FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION IF THERE IS ANY
LET'S BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL THREE SEVEN
SEVEN I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
LET'S NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SERVICE.
STE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
ONCE AGAIN PROP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
THREE SEVEN SEVEN. PLEASE. AND
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE. SIXTY
MISTER CAREY APOLOGISED
IMMIGRATED COMMITTEE ON THEIR
RESUME LINE THAT IS NOT USED
THEIR MUTE BUTTON. HE WOULD
HAVE RECENTLY SPOKEN. WELL NOW
GO TO LINE SIXTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
CURTIS PLAYING WITH-
CALIFORNIANS ARE BOTH.
REPRESENTING MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND BOB YOU'RE
READY FOR NURSING SO SORRY FOR
THE- ECHO I DON'T HAVE A
SPEAKER PHONE NOT SURE WHAT'S
GOING ON. HOWEVER- WE- OPPOSE
SB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. MEASURE
PROVIDE MORE CONTEST OF ACTION
THE OUT THIS ASSISTANCE ALSO
EXPANDS THE SCOPE- THIS ONE
LIFE PERFECT. WHERE PROJECT
CONCERNED ABOUT IT AUTHORIZER
GALA JUST- SYSTEM TO ADMINISTER
PRESCRIBED DRUGS. FOR INSTANCE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
MONITORING OF A PATIENT ON
CONSCIOUS SEDATION REQUIRES
UNINVITED INTO THE PATIENT SO
WHAT'S ISN'T- HUB AND LOGICAL
YOU JUST COULD ALSO BE
SIMULTANEOUSLY. ADMINISTERING
CONSCIOUS SEDATION REQUIRES
DIRECT OR IMMEDIATE SUPERVISION
THIS BILL ONLY REQUIRES ARE
RAISED IN A PRIVATE DRUGS UNDER
GENERAL SUPERVISION WHAT DOES
NOT MEAN THE PRESENCE OF THE
RADIOLOGY WHICH IS VERY
DANGEROUS- ULTIMATE WE-
QUESTIONED THE NECESSITY OF
CREATING THIS. NEW CATEGORY OF
HEALTHCARE WORKERS. AND ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE INTRODUCTION
OF A NEW TYPE OF PRACTITIONER
WILL LEAD TO MORE RIGHT MANY.
AIR FOR RADIO STATION. BOTH
POSITION ASSISTANCE AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS CAN FUNCTION IN
RADIOLOGY- NON POSITION ACTIVE.
THE INTERVENTIONAL RADIOLOGY
NURSE PRACTITIONER IS A
MASTER'S PREPARED PROVIDER THAT
COMPLEMENTS THE ROLE OF THE
READY OUT IT. THROUGH THE
APPLICATION OF IT AND THIS
TECHNICAL SKILLS THE CUTE CARE
AND AMBULATORY CARE SAID. IN
ADDITION TO POSITION ASSISTANT
AT S. PRACTITIONERS. CERTIFIED
RADIOLOGY MISSION REFORM
SPECIFIED OR I'M SORRY SUPPORT
OF SERVICES UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF RADIOLOGISTS BUT
THERE ARE NUMBER OF EXISTING
ROLES AND PRACTICE OR THE BILL
THE SUPPORT RADIOLOGIST WE NEED.
ALSO SOME HAVE ASSERTED. BY THE
CAREER LADDER FOR RADIOLOGY
WILL BE ALLOWED THE TECHNICIAN.
HOWEVER BECAUSE THE BILL
REQUIRE IN OUR A TO ALL WILL BE
A RADIOLOGICAL. THIS BILL WOULD
POTENTIALLY UNDERMINE THE
EMPLOYABILITY APART. WISH TO GO
ON TO BECOME AN RA BECAUSE
THERE WOULD BE LITTLE IN A BOY
BOTH AT THE SAME TIME. TO SOME
CIRCUMVENT THE FOR- FRAGMENTS
IN THE CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR
PATIENTS OFF MEDICATIONS.
RESPECT WITHOUT FOR YOUR NOBLE
TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT. SURE NO
ONE ELSE IS QUEUED UP TO SPEAK
I'M GOING TO A PROMPT AGAIN IF
YOU HAVE JOINED THIS CONFERENCE
CALL THIS COMMITTEE MEETING BY
ZOOM A EUROPE TALK BAR IS OPEN
DOOR IMPACTING THIS MEETING.
SLURRY WERE YOU CHECKING TO SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT
WE'VE NOT HEARD FROM. IF NOT
PLEASE DO. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ENTER AT THIS TIME. NO ONE
OUGHT TO SIGNAL IF THEY WISH TO
SPEAK MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S NOT BRING IT
BACK TO- THE CHAMBER AND MY
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS. OR
COMMENTS. ADDUCT PAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- THE I GUESS THE
QUESTION FOR- THAT'S ACTUALLY
ME WHEN ASKED HERE- SUPPORTERS
TO EXPLAIN. SO FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE THE RESEARCH
TECHNOLOGISTS AND WE HAVE THE-
THE RATE THE RADIOLOGY
ASSISTANCE BUT NOT. THE LEAST
THAT I CAN TELL FROM THE
TESTIMONY ANALYSIS IS ACTUALLY.
WHAT IS WHAT CAN THE ASSISTANCE
TO THAT THE TECHNOLOGIST CANNOT
SO WHAT IS THE DISTINGUISHING
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT THE
ASSISTANCE SO WE HEAR THAT YOU
KNOW THE SUBSISTENCE AND MORE
ADVANCED VERSION OF THE
TECHNOLOGIST. AND OF COURSE
CERTAINLY IS A POSITION I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE NO NEW
DANCES AND SORT OF IMAGING AND
SO FORTH. BUT CAN WE CLARIFY
AND THOSE SORT OF FLY BY THE
OPPOSITION WHAT IS THE
ASSISTANT DOING THAT THE
TECHNOLOGIST CANNOT THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CLEAR. THAT TO DO
THE- AT- THE DOES THIS BILL
STRANGE ADDRESS IN TERMS OF-
TRYING TO PROTECT. THE- THE
NAME SO. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
THE QUESTION A REFER TO MY-
EXPERTS YES. FOR EXAMPLE THE
FOR EXAMPLE DOCTOR CANOPY
RADIOLOGICAL FIFTEEN- WINNER
THIRTY CAN CAN HELP. THE IN
BETWEEN IN WHICH THE PATTERN
BUT THIRTY WILL GO- I WAS THE
FIRST TO BOB. B. LEGISLATION
VERY CLEAR WE GET THIS. I TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WENT TO THE
DOCTOR THE THEY WERE GOING TO
OPPOSITION. AND WE'RE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE RADIO. AT AT
IF YOU COULD AND THAT'S WHY DO
WE- THAT THEY WERE BROUGHT ON
BOARD BUT. OUR LADY WORK 50%
SENATE ROTH ABOUTWOULD HAVE
RESPOND. PERCY SO HERE LIKE THE
BALLOT JUST IS LICENSED UNDER A
LOT OF READY USING QUICKBOOKS-
THEY ARE NOT REALLY YOU KNOW
WHAT IT SCOPE OF TO DO ANY
OTHER- THERE'S A COUPLE PAY.
DISCUSS EXAMINATIONS. OF
PERFORMANCE OF. ANY
INTERVENTIONAL PROCEDURES SO
THE ARE A IS A BAND PRACTICE
FOR THE SKILL SETS ARE TAUGHT.
AND- EXPERIENCE WITH CLINICAL
PRECEPTOR SHIP. DAHLE REALLY
BROADENS WHAT IN ARE A CAN TO
TERMS OF REPLACING THE
RADIOLOGISTS FUNCTION. SO
THEY'RE MORE AKIN TO A RESPECT
FOR THE A SPECIFIC TO RADIOLOGY.
OKAY AND JUST TO CLARIFY
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION SAID
THAT WITH THE R. EIGHT V. DOING
ADDITIONAL PROCEDURES LIKE
ADMINISTERING MEDICATION OR
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS ARE NOT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THEIR MINISTRY.
MEDICATION THERE IS A- IS A
LIST OF SERVICES THAT ARE PART
OF THIS NATIONAL OCCASIONALLY
RIGHT TO YOU. BUT IT IS VERY
CONTRAST MEDIA IS SOMETHING
THAT ARE HE COULD YOU CAN
ALREADY WOULD DO AS WELL BUT
THERE ARE MINOR CONVICTION
PROCEDURES THAT ARE IS TRYING
TO TEACH. OKAY- THEY'RE NOT
PRESCRIBING. OKAY THEY'RE NOT
INVESTORS CLARIFIED THAT THEY
ARE NOT FIGHTING MEDICAL. OKAY
BY NO THAT'S VERY HELPFUL I
THINK COULD BE GOOD TO HAVE
CLARITY ON THAT- CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'D WANT TO.
HAVE BE SURE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
IDENTIFYING THEMSELVES AND THAT
WE DON'T- THE SEARCH FOR
PATIENTS AND SO FORTH- IT'D BE
HELPFUL TO HAVE SOME MORE
CLARITY BUT I THINK THIS IS
CERTAINLY. IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND-
APPRECIATE THE ANSWERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENTIMENT. THANK
YOU MR SO AND CONTINUING ALONG
THE LINES OF CENTER PANIC AS
I'M A LAYMAN- AND SO. YES MY
QUESTION IS A LIMIT. THAT BY
INTRODUCING A NEW STATUTORY
SCOPE OF PRACTICE I'M STILL
UNCLEAR WHAT EXACTLY WHAT
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE A PARTICULAR IN THIS
CASE WITH REGARD TO EITHER
QUALITY OF CARE OR COST OF CARE
DESPITE AYE I'VE MISSED IT- AND
I APOLOGIZE- IF IT'S BEEN CLEAR
TO THEM. ROTHA BY MAPPING
RESPOND AS WELL. PLEASE YES
PLEASE DO SURRENDER WHAT THANK
YOU FOR NEWMAN AT AN EXCELLENT
SO- THIS IS WHY PRESTON AND
BALAJI HAS BEEN ENHANCED. BURKE
IMAGES THAT RADIO HAS TO. IT A
SECURE THAT EXPEDITION CREATES.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY USED. TIMES
STAFF LIKE A P. A R. AND HE
DOES. BUT WHAT ARE EAGER IS
THAT BACK IN RADIO SAFE AND THE
BACKGROUND IS A RETAIL.
TECHNOLOGISTS THE REALLY
ENHANCES THE LEVEL OF
ASSISTANCE TO GET BY. AND THEIR
ADVANCED TRAINING CERTAIN THE
KRIMS ON LOMA LINDA AS OUR
PROGRAM FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY OUR REYES
THAT COME FROM THAT PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO PRACTICE THE FULLEST
OF THEIR TRAINING SO WITH THIS
BILL ALLOWS. THE RADIOLOGIST TO
CORPORATE IMAGE THEIR PRACTICE.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT BUT I
THINK AT LEAST. ONE OF THE-
SOMETHING'S FALLING HERE SO ONE
OF THE PREMISES BILL IS THAT
THIS WOULD PRECLUDE.
PROFESSIONALS WHO UP TO NOW
HAVE HAD A ROLE IN THE
CONTINUED CARE OF DOING SO IN
THE FUTURE UNDER THIS NEW
STATUTES. SURGICAL EXPLAINED IS
THAT THERE IS. NOT CLEAR TO ME
WHETHER THERE'S A NET BENEFIT
TO THAT- AND SO STILL NOT A
100% CLEAR SO IF YOU COULD SHED
A LITTLE MORE LIGHT ON THAT ARE
GONNA BE GRATEFUL. IT DOESN'T
IT DOES NOT PRECLUDE. THOSE WHO
ARE DOING WHAT THEY DO NOW.
WHAT IT ALLOWS THEY ALLOW IT
THIRTY OTHER STATES. IS THAT
THE R. HAYES WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK. IN A MORE ADVANCED WAY
WITH THE RADIOLOGIST IN TERMS
OF THE SYSTEM IT'S NOT BEING
DONE IN CALIFORNIA PARKING
PLACE AND THIS ALLOWS IT TO BE
DONE- AND OVER. OVERWHELMED
RADIOLOGIC PRACTICE BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A THIRTY
OTHER STATES THAT THE BANDS OF
JOBS AND HAVE A RADIOLOGIC
ASSISTANT. M- IN THEIR IN THEIR
JOB AND ALLOW THEM TO FOCUS AND
CONCENTRATE. THE MOTOR
RADIOLOGY SHOULD BE FOCUSING
AND CONCENTRATING ON. THANK YOU
MR IS THE DISPLACEMENT. YOU
KNOW HOW DO I CHANGE YOU KNOW
ONE R. EIGHT CANADAPART OF
DEBATE WE HAVE THIRTY ARE KEY.
THOSE ARE KEYS COULD YOU TO AS
A HAVE. MISPLACE OF. THANKS
MISTER THANK YOU- SENATORS
CENTER MAN. I WANTED TO JUST
FOLLOW UP ON CENTER NEWMAN'S
FINAL QUESTIONING- I ALSO THE
LAY PERSON I'M NEW TO THIS
COMMITTEE- AND I GUESS WHEN I
THINK OF OCCUPATIONAL BARRIERS
TO ENTRY- MY DISPOSITION ESTATE
GENERALLY NOT FAVOR THESE
UNLESS THERE'S SOME STRONG
REASON TO DO THAT. IN SO I
GUESS I'M I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE COST BENEFIT
RATIONALE THIS I CAN UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THE COST POTENTIALLY A
I ASSUME THIS WOULD DRIVE UP
MEDICAL COSTS- IT MIGHT LEAD TO
SHORTAGES IN THE NUMBER OF OUR
IS WE HAVE. A BUT WHAT I'M-HAVING TROUBLE UNDERSTANDING IS
WHAT THE BENEFITS ARE I GET THE
ARGUMENTS FROM RIGHT WANT THIS
BUT I HAVE THERE BEEN ANY
ATTEMPTS TO QUANTIFY OR EVEN
PROVIDE QUALITATIVE MEASURES OF
WHAT THE BENEFITS OF THIS WOULD
BE FOR- MEDICAL QUALITY OF CARE
FOR PATIENTS FOR TAXPAYERS FOR
ANYONE ELSE- I I'D BE VERY
INTERESTED TO HEAR THAT. THANK
YOU. SO SOUTHERN METHODIST
SPONGEBOB ACKERMAN AGAIN SO. I
DON'T THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
BE THIS IS DRIVING UP THE COST
OF CARE BECAUSE THE PERSON WE
DISPLAY CERTAIN HERBS WORK
QUICKLY ALEX. WHICH A PROBABLY
MORE EXPENSIVE COST HERE AND
ALL RIGHT. PLEASE EXPENSIVE SO
IT MAKE IT. RAILTRACK'S
CORPORATIONS DOESN'T RESEARCH
THE COST FOR THIS PURPOSE AND
OF BUILDING A RE. WE ALLOW THE
R. EIGHT PROVIDE OUR BUNCH OF
THE RADIOLOGIST AND DIRECTOR OR
ACTION AN ASSESSMENT THINGS
THAT ARE ARE KEEPING BE. HAVE
THEIR BEEN ANY STUDIES OR
RESEARCH HAS TAKEN A ANYTHING
YOU CAN POINT TO IT I JUST BE
CURIOUS AGAIN ONE OF THE
BENEFITS. FROM JUST FROM A PURE
QUANTITATIVE PERSPECTIVE WITH
THIS PROVIDES LIKE. YOUR TOWN I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD ARGUMENT
THAT ARE REYES WOULD LOWER THE
PROSPECT BUT HAS ANYONE ELSE AT
THIS. FINALLY VANGUARD. FOR BUT
I GOT IT RIGHT LOOK FOR A STUDY
BUT REALLY THAT COLLABORATION
HEARD OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS BETWEEN ONE PM ET
OURSELVES THE BILL'S BENEFIT IN
TERMS OF PRODUCTIVITY AND
EFFICIENCY- AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
TRY TO FIND YOU SOMETHING TO
THE EXTENT THAT WILL HAVE TO
FIGURE TIPS BUT- THE- BEEN DONE.
IN MANY OTHER STATES HER. MANY
YEARS. WITHOUT WE WELCOME DATA
COST PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU TO
BE VERY INTERESTED IN THAT ANY
DATA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. A CENTER JONES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I AT EIGHT
CENTER MEN'S CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY I SHARE THAT
pMY CONCERNS ON THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION EARLIER AND THE IN
THE LEGISLATURE INSERTING OUR
INFLUENCE INTO THESE MATTERS-
YOU KNOW I THE LEGISLATURE EVEN
I TAKE A MORE RESTRAINED
POSTURE- IN THESE TYPES OF
ISSUES WHEN IT COMES TO TITLE
PROTECTION AND EVENTUALLY
EVENTUALLY LEADS TO LICENSING
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF LICENSED PROFESSIONS
IN THE COUNTRY. AND IS THAT
JUST UNDERSCORES YOU KNOW MY-PERSPECTIVE THAT WE NEED TO BE
VERY VERY THOUGHTFUL AND SET A
HIGH HURDLE- ON THESE TYPES OF
ISSUES GOING FORWARD IN
LICENSING OR- TITLE RECOGNIZING
EVEN MORE PROFESSIONS THERE'S
NOTHING IN CURRENT LAW THAT WE
ARE EXEMPTS SOMEBODY FROM
CALLING THEMSELVES A-
RADIOLOGICAL AS- ASSISTANT- SO
I CAN SHARE THE CONCERN OF WHAT
PROBLEM ARE WE TRYING TO SOLVE.
BUT WITH ALL THAT SAID- EVEN IF
HIS DID- RISE TO THE LEVEL AND
JUMP THE HURDLE OF. BEING
NECESSARY REQUIRED. FOR
CALIFORNIA THE PENALTY ALONE IN
THIS BILL. REALLY CAUSES SOME
CONCERN THAT WE'RE GOING TO
JAIL PEOPLE. FOR VIOLATING THIS
POLICY OR FIND THEM UP TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHILE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS. LEADING
OTHER. MORE EGREGIOUS.
CRIMINALS OUT OF JAIL- I'M I'M
REALLY STRUGGLING WITH THAT
PENALTY PROVISION OF THE BILL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR COLLEAGUES ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER MELINDA'S. I THINK YOU
MISTER CHARGES HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE BILL AUTHOR BECAUSE AS-
AS- COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS CAME
OUT NOW I'M A LITTLE MORE
CONFUSED IS THE GOAL OF THE
BILL TO. REMOVE LIMITATIONS ON
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS IS THAT THE GOAL OF
THE BILL. OTHER THAN YOU KNOW
THAT THE TITLE ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE HERE. IF YOU RECALL WHEN
MY MADE MY PRESENTATION I
TALKED ABOUT THE SAFETY. OF AND
AT HIGH LEVEL OF SAFETY WHEN IT
COMES TO RADIATION. AND THE
FACT THAT- SOMEONE WOULD HAVE
THE SPECIALTY AS A RADIOLOGIST
SYSTEM TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AT THE HOSPITAL TO
PROTECT THE RADIOLOGIST AND THE
PATIENT- TO BE CERTIFIED TO DO
THAT EDUCATED TO DO THAT BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH. AND IT AND SOMEONE
WHO IS CALLING THEMSELVES THAT
RADIOLOGIST ASSISTANT WHICH IS
NOT TRAINED NOT AUTHORIZED
THAT'S WHERE THE PENALTY COMES
IN. BECAUSE WE HAVE TO PROTECT
THE CONSUMERS IN THIS OPENS THE
DOOR TO THAT AND- THE DIAGNOSIS
THAT I MENTIONED THE
RADIOLOGISTS- SITTING WITH THE
PATIENT AND THE DOCTORS- THAT
IS IN THE REALM OF THE OF THE
RADIOLOGIST BUT THE SYSTEM. IS
TO DO HIS OR HER JOB TO PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT ANYONE WHO CALLS
THEMSELVES A RADIOLOGIST
ASSISTANT. HAS IT HERE TO THE
LAW ON THE PRACTICE AND THAT'S
WHY THE VETERANS ADMINISTRATION
IS WORKING IN THAT SAME
DIRECTION AS WE ARE. TO ALLOW
THEM TO COME IN AND PROTECT OUR
VETERANS AND EVERYONE ELSE SO
WE WILL TAKE ANY AMENDMENTS IN
THE FUTURE I'D LIKE TO SEE THIS
BILL GO FORWARD. SO THEN WE CAN
MAKE SURE THE CONSUMER IS WELL
PROTECTED. THANK THANK YOU
CENTER CENTER EGGMAN. THANK
YOU- YEAH I WENT TO SCHOOL WITH
A LOT OF- MEDICAL TECHS AT FORT
SAM HOUSTON WHEN I WAS GETTING
MY MEDICAL TRAINING AT AS FAR
AS I KNOW THAT THE MILITARY HAS
NOT THAT QUANTIFY. THE
PROTECTION THAT YOU COULDN'T
NAME YOURSELF SOMETHING THAT
OTHERS CAN'T- AND I GUESS I
KNOW I'M OFFER TRAVEL
PROTECTION BUT I JUST DON'T
<c.yellow>NOW THAT WE NEED TO BE.</c>
CREATING NEW ONES RIGHT NOW WE
KNOW THERE'S A DEARTH OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
PROFESSIONALS AND A LOT OF
TIMES PEOPLE NEED TO HELP OUT
AND THINGS LIKE THIS. AND I
GUESS JUST AS AN ASIDE TO THIS
COMMITTEE CAN HEAR THAT BECAUSE
PEOPLE MAY NOT KNOW THAT THERE
IS NO TITLE PROTECTION FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS RIGHT A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK PEOPLE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE PHD BUT THERE
IS NO TITLE PROTECTION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW.
TRIED BEFORE ALL TRY AGAIN
BEFORE WE'RE DONE HERE BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME OF SOMEBODY WITH A
MASTER'S DEGREE IN A PROFESSION
DOES NOT HAVE THE PROTECTION TO
CALL THEMSELVES A SOCIAL WORKER
AND NOT TO HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
WHO MIGHT HAVE A JOB WITH THE
TITLE OF SOCIAL WORKER CALL
THEMSELVES AT. THAT I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO BE
CREATING HOLDING OUT CATEGORIES
AT THIS TIME DURING A PANDEMIC
FOR A RADIOLOGIST ASSISTANT
BURST A TECHNOLOGIST THOSE ARE
MY CONCERNS. THANK. YOU CENTER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE ADDRESS THAT
QUICKLY. YES PLEASE. NOW
APPROPRIATE TIME PEOPLE'S
WORKERS HOWEVER ARE STILL ALLOW.
PRACTICE OF THE FULLNESS OF
THEIR PER WHAT THIS DOES IS
WHAT IT ALLOWS YOU AND WHAT
YEAR'S AT THIS WE WERE GOING TO
DO MY JOB. AND THEN OUT NOT DO
LIFE INSURER TO DIG VITAL
PROTECTION AND THAT. BECAUSE
BUT BELIEF IS THAT BY
RECOGNIZING. YOU CAN. THEY CAN
DO WHAT THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
DO NOW BUT OFFERING WHICH IS TO
BE RECOGNIZED AS THEY ARE BUT
THE OTHER STATES. TO ASSIST
RADIOLOGY. ON THOSE TASKED WITH
WHICH THEY ARE SPECIFICALLY
QUALIFIED FRAME. AND ALLOW
THOSE RADIO. GREAT ON OTHER
RESPONSIBLE. IT WILL MAKE IT
WILL MAKE THEIR POCKETBOOK.
EIGHT EIGHT MORE OPPOSITION AND
ALLOW HIGHER MEDICAL DOCTORS.
THE FOCUS AND CONCENTRATE ON
WHAT THEY- AND THEY WORK ONLY
ONLY. THE SUPERVISION HELLO
RADIOLOGIST. THANK YOU LET ME
ASK IF I SEE NO OTHER MIKES UP
LET ME ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS-
I I'M OBVIOUSLY- I TRY TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF BILLS MOVING
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE. I'M
CONCERNED THAT HAVE BEEN N A
VARIETY OF WAYS OVER A VARIETY
OF YEARS WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT THAT WE- PUT UP HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
PARTICULARLY HERE GIVEN THE
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT WE'RE ON
DEADLY DEALING WITH. SO WHAT'S
THE COST OF THIS TRAINING IN
THE COST OF THIS EXAMINATION-
THAT ARE APPARENTLY REQUIRED IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE THIS REALLY
REALLY. RADIOLOGICAL ASSISTANT-
DESIGNATION AND TITLE. I DON'T
KNOW THE SPECIFIC COST OF THE
TEST. BUT I WILL TAKE IN TERMS
OF BARRIERS. NOBODY WHO'S
WORKING ON THE JOB THEY WANT TO
RIGHT NOW AS A TECHNOLOGIST IS
IN. IF AN INDIVIDUAL WANTS TO
BE A RADIOLOGIC ASSERTS. SO
WHAT'S THE COST OF THE AS SOON
AS TRAINING THAT'S REQUIRED AND
PRIOR TO AN EXAM. WHAT'S THE
COST OF THAT. GENERAL BOB
ACKERMAN I IT CERTAINLY THEY
DON'T KNOW SOMEONE OR MULTIPLE
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE A TWO YEAR
PROGRAM GLOBAL OFF BEFORE IT
GETS CLOSED FOR YOU NOT FOR
MUCH. SO IT'S A TWO BEDROOM
MULLIN IS A PER PRO SO IT'S A
TWO YEAR PRIVATE. THERE IS
OFTEN ELSEWHERE BUT THAT BROKE
THE PROPERTY CALIFORNIA. SO
WHAT'S THE DRIVING AND IN MOST
CASES. SO WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
IN THE AVERAGE PAY RATE BETWEEN
A- RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGIST OR
TECHNICIAN AND A RADIOLOGICAL
ASSISTANT. AGAIN I CAN'T GIVE
YOU A SPECIFIC NUMBER BUT OUR
KEYS ARE FAIRLY WELL
COMPETITION IN CALIFORNIA I
WOULD STAY BETWEEN NINETY AND A
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR. AND I THINK
IT'S AN ADVANCED LEVEL R. A.
YOU BE. AS THAT PICKED UP ON
THE VALUE DIFFERENT BRACKET.
BUT THOSE ARE NOT EMPLOYED IN
CALIFORNIA. WHAT'S PURPOSES NOW
I CAN'T GIVE YOU A- OR SALARY
RANGER OR BORDER CROSSINGS.
WELL I'LL GET TO THE BOTTOM
LINE BECAUSE THIS IS THIS WILL
TELL YOU WHERE I'M COMING FROM
AND SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE I CERTAINLY
WANT SOMEBODY TO THINK ABOUT
THISAND MY BASIC QUESTION IS
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE PARTIES
THAT ARE OUT THERE WORKING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ONE
AND TWO. ARE YOU SENATOR ARE
YOU CONCERNED. ABOUT CREATING
ORPHANS OUT OF THIS EXISTING.
CADRE OF. RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS AND TECHNICIANS
ARE EMPLOYED IN WORKPLACES ALL
UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THOSE ARE TWO
QUESTIONS AND THE REASON FOR
THE QUESTIONS AS WE HAVE WE
HAVE SEEN IT TO SOME EXTENT. IN
THE NURSING PROFESSION WORK
OUTSTANDING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NURSING PROGRAMS. TURNOUT
ASSOCIATE DEGREE IN NURSING.
STUDENTS BUT BECAUSE OF A
VARIETY OF PREFERENCES IN THE
HEALTH CARE. ENVIRONMENT
HOSPITALS AND OTHERS PREFER
BACHELOR'S DEGREE NURSES. AND
THEREFORE CREATE DIFFICULTY FOR
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
GRADUATES OF NURSING PROGRAMS
AND I'D CERTAINLY HATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CREATE. ANOTHER
RULE THAT CREATES ORPHANS OUT
OF FOLKS WHO WERE WORKING
DILIGENTLY IN THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSION UP AND DOWN THE
STATE BECAUSE- EMPLOYERS NOW
PREFER. TO HIRE RADIOLOGICAL
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE THE PAY
DIFFERENTIAL MAY NOT BE THAT
MUCH. OVER THE OUR TEASER
CURRENTLY QUALIFIED IN
PERFORMING WORK. HELLO MY
QUESTION MAKES SENSE DOES NOT
NECESSARILY NEED TO BE EVER
RESPONDED TO UNLESS YOU CHOOSE
TO RESPOND. SENATOR IF I I'VE I
MAY ONCE AGAIN THE TITLE AS THE
RADIO SYSTEM AND TO PROTECT
THAT TITLE THAT'S THE
FOUNDATION BUT ALONG WITH THAT
IS THE ELEMENTS OF EDUCATION
THE ELEMENTS OF A GROWTH WITHIN
THE INDUSTRY. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IS THE FACT THAT
THESE PRACTITIONERS ARE THERE
TO PROVIDE SAFETY IN RADIATION
SAFETY AND ASSISTANCE- FOR THE
CONSUMER AND IF THIS BILL GOES
FORWARD THEN WHATEVER
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PUT TOGETHER TO CONTINUE THE
WE'RE OPEN TO THAT. BUT GIVEN
THIS OPPORTUNITY WE WILL FIND
THAT- ALONG WITH THE VETERANS
HEALTH ADMINISTRATION ALONG
WITH- LARGE- HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS THAT NEEDED TO WELL
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED
INDIVIDUALS THAT'S WHAT THIS
DOOR WILL OPEN. THANK CENTER I
SEE NO OTHER MIKES UP. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND I WILL
CLOSE WITH THOSE LAST COMMENTS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU'RE
ABLE TO MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA- DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON SENATE BILL
THREE SEVEN SEVEN CENTER MEN
THOSE BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR MAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM SEVEN SENATE
BILL THREE SEVEN SEVEN SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THE PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY ROTH. ROTH AYE
MELENDEZ. ARCHULETA LINE FOR TO
LET I'D THESE. BAKER DODD I
THOUGHT I EGGMAN. FOR TAUGHT
AT. HIGH PHOTO ID JONES NO
JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA EIGHT
MILLION FIVE MILLION I NEWMAN.
I CHAU ABODE. PAN HI CAN I. THE
VOTE CURRENTLY IS- SEVEN EYES
ONE NO WILL PUT THIS BILL ON
CALL. HE SARGE A LETTER YOU
HAVE ITEM NUMBER NINE. YES SIR
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHT FOUR
PROCEED. THANK YOU- ONCE AGAIN
THANKYOU- GERMAN RAFI
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM HERE 2%
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY FOUR.
REGARDING LICENSED PLUMBER
LICENSED PLUMBING CONTRACTOR
REPAIR EXEMPTIONS EXEMPTION AND
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY SAYING
THAT I WILL AND HAVE ACCEPTED
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE PUT THAT ON THE TABLE RIGHT
AWAY. UNDER CURRENT LAW
PLUMBING CONTRACTORS ARE
LICENSED BY THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSING BOARD AND ARE
CERTIFIED TO PERFORM SEWER
LATERAL INSPECTIONS. AND MAKE
REPAIRS BASED ON THEIR
INSPECTIONS IN THESE
INSPECTIONS ARE NOW BEING
REQUIRED TIME AND TIME AGAIN BY
CITIES AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. A HOME INSPECTION BY
A PHYSICAL EXAMINATION OF A
HOME. INCLUDED BUT NOT LIMITED
TO SOME PLUMBING SYSTEMS
ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS HAS SYSTEM
HEATING SYSTEMS AND GENERAL
MAINTENANCE PERFORMED FOR A
FREE IN CONNECTION WITH THE
TRANSFER REAL PROPERTY AND
THESE DISCLOSURE REQUIRED- IN
MANY FORMS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION REALTORS. AND THE
DISCLOSURES BY THE SELLER TO
THE BUYER OR VITAL IN THE
TRANSACTION. SEWER LATERAL
INSPECTIONS ARE NOT PART OF A
TRADITIONAL HOME INSPECTIONS
SEWER LATERAL INSPECTIONS WHICH
ARE INTENDED TO IDENTIFY SEWER
LEAKS ARE REQUIRED BY AS I
MENTIONED CITIES AND COUNTIES.
AT THE TIME WHEN THE HOME WAS
SOLD AND THE COUNTY RECORDER
HAS KNOWLEDGE OF A TRANSFER.
EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS HOME
INSPECTOR A HOME INSPECTION
COMPANY OR EMPLOYEE OF A HOME
INSPECTION COMPANY FOR
PERFORMING WORK ON ANY HOME.
WHICH THEY HAVE EXPECTED IN THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS. THESE
PROHIBITIONS ARE IN LAW BECAUSE
HOME INSPECTORS ARE NOT
LICENSED HOWEVER PLUMBER'S
LICENSE BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE LICENSING
BOARDS ARE ALLOWED TO INSPECT
AND REPAIR SEWER LATERAL.
DAMAGE CURRENTLY IT IS
CONSIDERED UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICE FOR PLUMBING
CONTRACTED TO DO BOTH THE SEWER
INSPECTION AND THE SEWER REPAIR
IF THE COMPANY HAS ALSO
CONDUCTED A HOME INSPECTION ON
THE SAME PROPERTY. SENATE BILL
FORTY FOUR CORRECTS THIS
PROBLEM ALLOWS CONSUMERS MORE
CHOICES AND ALLOW THEM TO BE
MORE INVOLVED TO SAVE TIME SAVE
MONEY AND TO REVIEW THE
INSPECTION- THAT IS PROVIDED BY
THE LICENSE PLUMBER. SENATE
BILL EIGHT FORTY FOUR CLARIFIES
THAT A LICENSED PLUMBING
CONTRACTOR CAN MAKE REPAIRS TO
A SEWER LATERAL PIPE. THEY HAVE
INSPECTED EVEN IF THEY OR THEIR
COMPANY HAS PERFORMED A HOME
INSPECTION ON THE SAME PROPERTY.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN CHIU PROVIDED AN
EXEMPTION FOR LICENSE ROOF
INSPECTORS SENATE BILL FORTY
FOUR WOULD PROVIDE A SIMILAR
EXEMPTION FOR THE SPECIALIST
LICENSED PLUMBERS. SENATE BILL
FORTY FOUR PROTECT CONSUMERS
WHILE ALLOWING THEM TO CHOOSE A
LICENSED PLUMBING CONTRACTOR TO
CONDUCT THE SEWER LATERAL
INSPECTION AND MAKE ANY NEEDED
REPAIRS EVEN IF THE PLUMBERS
COMPANY HAS PERFORMED HOME
INSPECTION ON THE SAME PROPERTY
IN THE PAST. FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS TODAY I HAVE TRANSMIT
REPRESENTING OUR BILL SPONSORED
HOME GUARD TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
JACKSON- MISTER SMITH PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS TRANSMIT
ON BEHALF OF HOME GUARD SPONSOR
OF THE BILL. THE INTENT OF THE
BILL IS TO ADDRESS. LOOKING
BODY THE WALL ONE DEALING WITH
THE REGULATION OF HOME
INSPECTORS- ARE UNLICENSED AND
THEREFORE PROHIBITED FROM
MAKING. ANY REPAIRS UNDER A
HOME INSPECTION- AND THE SECOND
BODY OF LAW WHICH DEALS WITH
LICENSED CONTRACTORS IN THIS
CASE PLUMBERS WHO ARE IN FACT
ALLOWED TO MAKE REPAIRS BASED
ON THEIR INSPECTION- THE
PROBLEM EXISTS IF A COMPANY-
OFFERS BOTH INSPECTIONS A HOME
INSPECTION AND A SEWER LATERAL
INSPECTION. THE MERE FACT THAT
THEY'VE DONE A HOME INSPECTION
ON THE PROPERTY DAMAGE LIMITS
THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE A SEWER
REPAIR EVEN THOUGH THERE
LICENSE UNDER THEIR PLUMBING
LICENSE. WE ARE NOT ALLOWING
REPAIRS BE MADE UNDER THE HOME
INSPECTION REPORT THESE ARE TWO
SEPARATE REPORTS- WILL ONLY
ALLOWING REPAIRS UNDER THE
TERMS OF THE PLUMBING LICENSE-
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT EIGHTY SEWER LATERAL
INSPECTION IS DONE UP WITH KGO
CAMERA AND S THE CONSUMER IS
PROVIDED. THE EITHER VIDEO
EVIDENCE OR PHOTOGRAPHIC
EVIDENCE FOR THE NEED FOR A
REPAIR. THERE ARE SEVERAL
CONSUMER DISCLOSURES REQUIRED
UNDER THE BILL WILL MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR TO THE CONSUMER THAT
IF THEY AUTHORIZED THE REPAIR
TO THEIR SEWER LATERAL- THEY
ARE NOT AUTHORIZED THE HEATING
REPAIRS PROVIDED UNDER THE HOME
INSPECTION REPORT SO WE ARE
KEEPING BOTH REPORTS-
SEPARATELY AND REPAIRS ARE ONLY
ALLOWED. IN THE PLUMBING REPORT
NOT THE HOME INSPECTION REPORT
AGAIN THERE AREN'T THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION. AND WE RESPECT
COOLEY APPS YOUR MICRO. THANK
YOU SIR WE WILL NOW HEAR ANY
WITH AND IN THE GALLERY AND I
NO WITNESSES ARE THERE A
WITNESS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHICH TO FINDS. OF SENATE BILL
FIVE I SEE WITNESS LET'S NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD BEGIN TO PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FORTY FOUR
WE WILL BEGIN WITH THAT PROCESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO PRESS. ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAD SEVERAL PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE GOING TO NOW
GO TO LINE SEVENTY SIX. ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN-
JERRY MEMBERS MY NAME IS GERRY
DESMOND IN TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA REAL ESTATE
INSPECTION ASSOCIATION. HARD
LEGISLATIVE CHAIR DAVE PACE
WILL ALSO BE TESTIFYING TO
TESTIFYING AS TO OUR MUTUAL
POSITION ON THE MEASURE AS THE
AUTHOR HAS AMENDED THE BILL
TODAY WANTED TO POINT OUT WE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION THE
DIALOGUE WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE IN THE COMMITTEES
OPPOSITE. THAT ARE REFLECTED IN
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING
TAKEN AND I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
ADD ONE ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION AND THAT IS THAT
WE LOOK UP HOME INSPECTORS TO
CONDUCT TODAY. SUPPORT LATERAL
INSPECTION SO IT'S- JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT STATEMENT FOR
THE. COMMITTEE THANK YOU NEXT.
THANKS COMMITTEE CHAIR WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE THIRTY.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. BY THIRTY
ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID HEY I AM
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
REAL ESTATE INSPECTION
ASSOCIATION LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
PRIYA WE ARE ONE OF THE LARGEST
AND OLDEST TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
OF HOME INSPECTORS IN THE
NATION. WE HAVE BEEN PLEASED TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE ON THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE BEING MADE TODAY
QUESTION THOSE AMENDMENTS
CREATE A HAS A NEUTRAL POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. SURE NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME.
OKAY- AT THE RISK OF PROLONGING
THIS WOULD YOU CHECK TO SEE ONE
MORE TIME IF WE'D HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES ON AS
P. FORTY FOUR. AND AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO P. WISH TO SPEAK. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE FINE.
WHEN I FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
LET'S CHECK THE GALLERY I SEE
NO WITNESSES LET'S CHECK ROOM
ONE TWELVE THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF. S. B.
FORTY FOUR I SEE NO WITNESSES
THERE LET'S ONCE AGAIN MOVED TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE SERVICE THIS TIME IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
FORTY FOUR. I WOULD APPRECIATE
IT MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU.
MR IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE AND ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU LET'S NOT BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
CHAMBER. AND MY COLLEAGUES
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS DR PAN. I THANK YOU
SHARE- CIRCULAR APPRECIATE-
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO BRING
FORWARD I KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS. I GUESS YEAH
LEVINE MY CONCERN IS WE HAVE
THE CONFLICT OF INTEREST RULES
TO PREVENT- ESSENTIALLY
CREATING INCENTIVES PARTICULAR
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES OR SOMEONE
TO. FIND SOMETHING ON
INSPECTION REPORT WHICH THEM
COULD AFFECT THEIR ABILITY TO
SELL THEIR HOME OR THE VALUE OF
THEIR HOMES BECAUSE- THE
PURCHASER WOULD NOT WANT TO
FIGHT YOU KNOW HAVE A DEFECT ON
THEIR- AND THEN- THE SAME
PERSON'S DOING INSPECTION IS
ALSO DOING THE REPAIR. THERE'S
PERHAPS AN INCENTIVE FOR THEM
TO FIND A PROBLEM RIGHT BECAUSE
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SOME MONEY. AND WHY DO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU MENTIONED
THAT SOMEONE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT
THE VIDEO I MEAN A LAY PERSON
IS PROBABLY YOU KNOW THOSE OF A
FARMER SAYS WELL THERE'S A
PROBLEM THERE- IT HARD FOR A
LAYPERSON SAID WELL NO THERE
ISN'T AND- BY THE WAY IT'S
GONNA SHOW UP ON INSPECTION
REPORTS SO I AM GOING TO HAVE
TO. YOU KNOW HI IS A- SELLER OF
THE HOME. I AM GOING TO HAVE TO
EXPLAIN TO ANY PURCHASER THAT
WELL ACTUALLY I DISAGREED WITH
THE PLUMBER- BUT IT'S STILL
INSPECTION REPORT SO BASICALLY
I'M STUCK AND HAVING REPAIRED-
SO CAN YOU TELL ME NOW OF
COURSE AGAIN THE OTHER REASON
FOR INSPECTION IS TO BE SURE
THAT THE PURCHASER HAS AN
ACCURATE. ASSESSMENT OF THE PER
PROPERTY DEVICE SO CAN YOU
EXPLAIN TO ME ASIDE FROM THE
VIDEO PART. WHAT IS IT WHAT ARE
THE PROTECTIONS THAT PREVENT
THE ESSENTIALLY THE PLUMBER WHO
IS ALSO BY THE WAY IN THIS CASE
EMPLOYEE BY THE INSPECTION
COMPANY SO EVEN THOUGH I DIDN'T
STAND INSPECTOR THE PLUMBER TO
SEPARATE PEOPLE. IF THE PLUMBER
WHO IS INDEED WHO'S EMPLOYED BY
THE INSPECTION COMPANY IS DOING
INSPECTION REPORT- NOT HAVE A
CONFLICT OR WHAT KIND OF THINGS
ARE YOU DOING TO BEFRIEND BE
SURE THERE IS A FINANCIAL
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE PERSON
DOING THE INSPECTION. AND THE
PERSON DOING THE REPAIR TOOL
THAT PROFIT FROM CONDUCTING
THOSE REPAIRS. THAT WERE
ESSENTIALLY- WELL I MEAN IN
CITED BY A BECAUSE- A-
INSPECTION FINDINGS SO HOW DO
WE BE SURE THAT. WE PROTECT
CONSUMERS AGAINST A POTENTIAL
SALE BEING LEVERAGED TO THANK
YOU FOR TO SERVICES THAT- THAT-
WELL THAT- MAY NOT HAS TO BE
WELL BASICALLY WE SAW I CREATE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR- SOMEONE THE
LEVERAGE SOMEONE TO. IT TO MAKE
MONEY. CENTER I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
AT THE END OF THE- EXPERT HAS%
ANYTHING YOU COULD DO A JUMP IN
WITH. BUT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IN THE DAY THAT ARE MY
I AM A LICENSED REAL ESTATE
BROKER- I HAVE REPRESENTED-
NUMEROUS CLIENTS OVER THE
YEARS. AND I'VE WORKED WITH
NUMEROUS HOME INSPECTION
COMPANIES AND- WE LOOK FOR THE
MOST PROFESSIONAL MARCH
FEDERAL- HOME INSPECTION
COMPANY IF WE COULD FIND. AT
THE REPUTATION IS ACROSS THE
BOARD- IF IT'S BAD EVERYONE
STAYS AWAY FROM IT IF IT'S GOOD
EVERYONE WILL GO TO IT AND
THAT'S WHERE THE ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. HAS ASSOCIATE MEMBERS
WHO ARE IN GOOD STANDINGS
THAT'S NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO
IF THE HOME INSPECTION COMPANY
IS LARGE ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO
EMPLOY A LICENSED PLUMBER. THAT
WILL COME ON BOARD ONLY IF THE
HOME INSPECTION. REVEALS THAT
THERE MIGHT BE DAMAGE IN THE
LATERAL LINE OR THE FACT THAT
THE LATERAL LNE MUST BE
INSPECTED FOR THE COUNTY OR
CITY REQUIREMENT BEFORE. IT
TRANSFERRED BECAUSE WE HAVE TWO
SCENARIOS ONE THAT THE HOME
INSPECTION TURNED ON THE WATER
FAUCETS AND EVERYTHING ELSE IT
IT'S SLOW THE PLAN MUST BE AN
ISSUE SO SOMETHING MUST BE
CAUSINGTHE PROBLEM. THAT THEY
RECOMMENDED THAT THE LICENSE A
PLUMBER DO. A LATERAL
INSPECTION. SO THERE IS THIS
CLOSE THAT THEY HAVE SOMEONE ON
STAFF THAT CAN DO THAT AND
REMEMBER AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW THIS BUT- THE HOME
INSPECTION- CONSIST OF THE
PLUMBING HEATING ELECTRICAL-
THE AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES- ALL ACROSS THAT THE
HOME BECAUSE- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IS
LOOKING FOR A GOOD SOLID
DISCLOSURE STATEMENT. BY THE
SELLER SO IF THE SELLER HAS
KNOWLEDGE OF SOMETHING BY LAW
THEY HAVE TO DISCLOSE IT IF
THEY DON'T. THEN THE INSPECTION
WOULD DISCOVER IT AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT HAVE A
GOOD DILIGENT INSPECTION MADE
THAT WILL REVEAL THESE THINGS
SO WHEN THE HOME INSPECTION
REVEALS THAT- IT MUST GO TO THE
NEXT LEVEL THE EXPERT THE
LICENSE- PLUMBER. THEN HE WILL
FIND IT AND THEN HE'LL LOOK AT
AND SIT DOWN WITH THE HOMEOWNER
AND SAY THIS IS WHAT I FOUND
THESE ARE MY RECOMMENDATIONS
HERE'S THE VIDEO HERE THE
PICTURES. AND YOU HAVE THE
CHOICE TO USE THE SERVICES OF
THAT PARTICULAR COMPANY OR
SOMEONE ELSE AND AS YOU KNOW AS
WELL AS I DO THAT ALL OF US
HAVE A FRIEND OF A FRIEND. WHO
IS A PLUMBER ELECTRICIAN AND SO
ON SO MORE THAN LIKELY THE
CONSUMER MIGHT GET ANOTHER- BID
AND- OR GET THREE BIDS THIS IS
WHAT'S RECOMMENDED BY THE
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS THREE
BIDS. SO THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
DO THAT SO THE CONSUMER ALWAYS
HAS THE OPTION TO DO THAT. AND
SO IN REFERENCE TO ANY CONFLICT
OF INTEREST I THINK THE
DISCLOSURE BY THE HOME
PROTECTION COMPANY THE
DISCLOSURE BY THE REALTOR
HIMSELF. WITH THE FULL
KNOWLEDGE THAT THIS HOMEOWNER
HAS THE OPTION TO GET THREE
BIDS I THINK THERE'S A
PROTECTION THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR. BUT AGAIN THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION IS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IN THE COURSE OF
BEING ABLE TO. MEET THAT
STANDARD THAT THE CITY OR
COUNTY HAS PUT ON THE TABLE AND
NOT ALL OF THEM DO NOT. ALL OF
THEM DO. BUT WHEN IT'S REQUIRED
THIS IS THE BEST WAY TO DO IT
WITH A LICENSE- PLUMBER. SO IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT- MY-
EXPERT LIKE TO ADD- PLEASE JOIN
IN. SURE MISTER CHAIRMAN OKAY
WE HEAR THIS IN THE
ENTRENCHMENT- THE ONLY OTHER
THING I WOULD ADD AND AS
REMEMBER BECAUSE OF THE COMPANY
OF THE LICENSED PLUMBER- THERE
IS ADDED CONSUMER PROTECTION
THAT IF THEY FEEL THERE IS
ANYTHING FRAUDULENT GOING ON A
REPAIRS ARE BEING RECOMMENDED.
OR NOT WARRANTED AND AGM FILED
COMPLAINTS OR THEY CAN CHECK IN
ADVANCE- WITH ON THAT COMPANY
TO SEE IF THEY HAVE COMPLAINTS
FILED AGAINST THEM AND THE
BALL'S MONTHLY THE STATE
CONTRACTORS BOARD DOES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO FIND THE FOUNDER
REVOKE A PLUMBER'S LICENSE THAT
THEIR- ACT THE FRAUDULENTLY SO
THERE IS THAT ACT THAT ADDED.
BENEFIT OF KNOWING IN A LICENSE
AND TO THE IS BEING REGULATED
AND OVERSEEN BY. STATE AGENCIES.
OKAY CERTAINLY A UNDERSTAND
THAT THE FORMER DEBTS LICENSE
SERVICES TO- MAINTAIN THEIR
LICENSE- I AM CONCERNED THAT-
UNLESS THERE'S SUFFICIENT
WORKER PROTECTIONS THAT- IS
THAT SUMMER'S ACTUALLY AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE SAME COMPANY
THAT'S CONDUCTING THE
INSPECTION THAT SO THEY'RE BOTH
INSPECTOR ANDERSON THE PERSON
OFFERING TO FIX SAID THERE IS
NO POTENTIAL CHALLENGE UNLESS-
YOU KNOW. CONFLICT THERE AND
UNLESS. FOR SOME REASON THE
PLUMBER- WELL GUESS THE- THE
QUESTION IS THAT WITH THE SAME
COMPANY THAT STATE INSPECTION
ALSO THEN PROFIT BY HAVING THE
REPAIR DONE BY THEIR OWN
PLUMBER TODAY IN FLOYD I THINK
IT'S STILL STILL BIT
PROBLEMATIC BUT I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR EXPLANATION CERTAINLY AYE
YUP BOW TO YOUR SUPERIOR
EXPERIENCE IN REAL ESTATE I'VE-
PERSONALLY FEEL OF COURSE THAT
BIDEN TOLD A COUPLE HOUSES AS
AND IN MY LIFETIME- NOT NOT TO
USE SLF BUT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT KNOWING HOW IMPORTANT
INSPECTOR REPORT IS- TO SELLING
A HOUSE- I DO HAVE CONCERNS BUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ANSWER. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
COLLEAGUES- I WOULD REMIND YOU
WE ARE NOWAFTER THE HOUR OF
TWELVE NOON WE HAVE ALL TURNED
INTO PUMPKINS SO FOR THOSE OF
YOU WITH QUESTIONS AND THOSE OF
YOU RESPONDING I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU WOULD BE
AS CONCISE AS POSSIBLE WHILE
GETTING THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU NEED IN ORDER TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION SENATOR
NEWMAN- ANYTHING CHURCHILL
CENTER PROJECT YOU DONE MY WORK
FOR ME TODAY- AND I'M HAVING
ONE OF THE STATION REMOTE
DIGITAL MOMENTS IT WAS ACTUALLY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN- HE AND I WERE
BOTH ON THE SAME COMMITTEE AND
WE HEARD AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH ACTUALLY. PERTAIN
TO ROOFERS AND I THINK PROBABLY
COINCIDENTALLY- THE SPONSOR
WITH THE SAME COMPANY AS TODAY
I SHARE SENATOR PANTS
CONCERNED- ABOUT THAT NOT JUST
CONFLICT OF INTEREST BUT THE
ISSUE PROVIDING THE ASSURANCE
TO CONSUMERS THAT THEY'RE NOT
SUBJECT TO CONFLICT OF INTEREST
IN A PARTICULAR AT A MOMENT.
THAT IS- YOU KNOW THE END OF
SORT OF. WITH RISK AND A BIG-
IF FROM- PEOPLE MOST FAMILIES-
AND SO I HAVE MISSED GIVE. NOT
A THIS- BUT ABOUT THE BROADER.
CERTIFICATIONS HERE THIS IS
PRECISELY WHY IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN YOU HAVE YOUR CAR SMOG
CHECKED- THAT THE COMPANY DOING
THE CHECK IS NOT ALLOWED TO DO
THE REPAIRS. TO PROVIDE THAT
SIMILAR ASSURANCE TO CONSUMERS-
INSIDE I WILL PROBABLY STAY OF
THE BILL TODAY GIVEN THAT- AND
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK
ON THIS. THANK YOU SIR AND I
SEE- NO OTHER. MIKES UP NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SERRAJ LETTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU THIS YEAR.
ONCE AGAIN- MY COLLEAGUES THIS
BILL. IS A CONSUMER PROTECTION
BILL IN REALITY BECAUSE THE
FACT THAT THE CONSUMER DOES
ALWAYS HAVE THE OPTION. AND IT
IS ALWAYS DISCLOSED BY THE
REALTORS THE HOME INSPECTION
COMPANY. THAT THEY CAN'T GET-
THE FINAL INSPECTION BY
LICENSED PLUMBER OF THEIR
CHOICE. SO THE EXEMPTION I
THINK WILL- CREATE- AN
AWARENESS IT WILL CREATE THE
SENSE OF- OF SAFETY. WHEN A
PROPERTY IS BEING TRANSFERRED.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SIR DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. ON AS P. FORTY FOUR.
ASSEMBLY CENTER DOES. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE ON FILE ITEM NINE
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
SENATOR OR CHILL OUT A FEW
PASSES AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RALPH HI. RALPH HI MELENDEZ.
ARCHULETA TO WHAT I'D BE HI
BATES AYE BACKER. DODD I
THOUGHT I'D- FOR TARO I FOR
TARA ALL RIGHT JONES JONES I
LEYVA I LEAVE US A MAIN NEWMAN.
A SHOW ABOUT. HI A TO ABOUT HE.
YES IT WORKS MELENDEZ I. DID
YOU HEAR ME NOW. MELENDEZ I
STARTED- MELENDEZ I. THE VOTE
IS AYE AYES NINE NOES ZERO WILL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU
MR THANK YOU OUR FINAL ITEM
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. SENATOR
COVER EURO SENATE BILL. FOUR
ZERO NINE. POSTED ME WHAT'D.
ALL OVER. WELL. I WISH CENTER
CABALLERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. A LOT. IN
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ISSUED A
WAIVER LAST ME TO ALLOW
PHARMACISTS TO ORDER AN
ADMINISTER COVERED NINETEEN
TESTS IN THE STATE. IN AUGUST
OF TWENTY TWENTY THE DCA
DIRECTOR ISSUED AN ORDER
WAIVING SPECIFIED PROFESSIONAL
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS AND
AMENDING THE SCOPES OF PRACTICE
OF PHARMACISTS AND PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS TO ALLOW THEM TO
PERFORM. WAIVED POINT OF CARE
TEST USED TO DETECT SARS
COMMITTEE TOO. ALONG WITH THE
WAIVER GUIDANCE WAS RELEASED TO
INFORM AND EDUCATE PHARMACIES
PHARMACISTS AND PHARMACISTS
PHARMACY TECHNICIANS OF
CLINICAL LABORATORY
REQUIREMENTS THAT APPLY ENTERED
THE DCA ORDER. UNDER EXISTING
LAW PHARMACISTS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE CERTAIN
CLIA WAIVED TESTS. THOSE ARE
CLINICAL LABORATORY IMPROVEMENT
AMENDMENTS CONTEST IN AN EFFORT
TO INCREASE INCREASE EFFICIENCY
SB FOUR OH NINE SECURES A MORE
PERMANENT SOLUTION THROUGH
STATUTORY CHANGES THAT
FACILITATE THE AUTHORITY FOR
PHARMACISTS. TO PERFORM THESE
CLIA WAIVED CORBIN AND
INFLUENZA TESTING IN A SAFE
MATT MATTER. THE BILL
FORMALIZES THE DCA ORDER AND
AUTHORIZES A PHARMACIST OR A
PHARMACY TO PERFORM UNDER
SPECIFIED CONDITIONS ANY ASPECT
OF AN FDA APPROVED TEST. FOR
THE PRESENCE OF SARS COVERED TO
THE VIRUS THAT CAUSES COBIT
NINETEEN OR INFLUENZA THAT IS
CLASSIFIED AS WAIVED UNDER THAT
THE CLEAR RULES. MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THOSE IN
MY DISTRICT FACED SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN OBTAINING ACCESS
TO TESTING AND VACCINES FROM
THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC.
PEOPLE TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES IN
ORDER TO OBTAIN PRESCRIPTIONS
TESTING AND NOW TO RECEIVE
THEIR VACCINES MOST OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PHARMACIES THESE LOCATIONS HAVE
BEEN KEY PILLARS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. PRE PANDEMIC AND
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC HAVE
SERVED AS LIFELINES TO OUR
RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS LIKE MY DISTRICT WERE
AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE IS DIFFICULT TO COME
BY. IT IS CRITICAL TO UTILIZE
THIS RESOURCE AND THE HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE MORE PHARMACISTS TO
EXPAND MUCH NEEDED ACCESS TO
TESTING IN OUR COMMUNITY. THIS
BILL DOES NOT EXPAND THEIR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE BEYOND THE
CURRENT EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE IS
ANSATA GRAND WITH THE STATE
BOARD OF PHARMACY. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU SIR.
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON ROB AND
OF THE COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR CALVING EUROPE OR
OFFERING THAT MEASURE AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS CONSIDERATION
OF THIS IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE. THE BOARD IN THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION AGENCY
CHARGED WITH REGULATING THE
PRACTICAL PHARMACY. SENATE BILL
FOUR ZERO NINE BUILT UPON THE
CURRENT LABOR ISSUED BY THE DC
DIRECTOR. FRANCO THE TESTING
CAPACITY AND ACCESS POINTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THE MEASURE UNDER
CONSIDERATION TODAY WOULD ALLOW
FOR ABOUT WAITED HOPING
NINETEEN AND IMPLEMENTED. TAX
THE BOARD BELIEVES THE
PERMITTED EXPAND THE FOR FIVE
IN THIS MEASURE IS IN THE BACK
INTEREST OF. AND IF YOU WITH
KNOWLEDGE SKILLS AND ABILITIES
OF OUR- FURNACES EDUCATION
INCLUDE A FOR YEAR COLLEGE
SPARKLE. DR OUR DEGREE. UNDER
THE ACCREDITING STATE
CURRICULUM. PUBLIC HEALTH WE
STRATEGIES NATIONAL COMMITTEE
BASED PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
ACTIVITIES THAT ADVANCE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WELLNESS. FURTHER I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT RECENTLY UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY NINE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ARMITAGE FOR GRANTED
THE AUTHORITY TO PERFORM HIV
AWAY ACTING. HERNANDEZ FORTY
FOUR PHARMACISTS REFORM THESE
TESTS AFFECT THE FIGHT IN THE
BILL IT'S NOT THE PURPOSE AND-
TO INSURE CALIFORNIANS NOT LOSE
THE EXPANDED AGUIAR-CURRY WHEN
HE EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS WITH
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOUR. CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW TO SUPPORT
WITNESSES HERE IN THE- I SEE NO
WITNESS IN THE GALLERY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FOUR OH
NINE I SEE NO WITNESSES. LET'S
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
PROMPTING. THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR OH NINE. WE WILL
BEGIN THANK YOU. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
ZERO NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN THAT IS ONE DOWN.
ZERO I HAVE NO WHEN QUEUING UP
ON THE PHONE PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU BUT A MODERATOR LET'S
NOT FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION LET'S
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. I SEE NO WITNESSES
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
AGREES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL I SEE NO
WITNESSES. LET'S NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SERVICE MURDERER MODERATOR IF
YOU BELIEVE BEGIN THE PROP
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY WE WILL BEGIN. IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
FOR S. B. FOUR ZERO NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT IS.
ONE TEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
SHOWING UP ON THE PHONE PLEASE
CONTINUE LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO COLLEAGUES
IN THE CHAMBER COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. DR PAN I
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU YOU MISTER
I KNOW IT'S GETTING LATE BOB
GOOD QUICK QUICK QUESTION I
GUESS- NO PROBLEM WITH THE
PHARMACIST DOING THE NON PLEA-
THE CLIA WAIVED. YES I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF
THE- INCLUDING A PHARMACIST IN
CHARGE OF THE DEFINITIONAL
LABORATORY DIRECTOR- BUT HE CAN
JUST DO A BRIEF EXPLANATION IN
YOUR CLOTHES AND- SO IT'S JUST
A CONCERN I HAVE US STILL VOTE
FOR THE BILL TO MOVE FORWARD
BUT HOPE WE CAN ADDRESS THAT.
THAT SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE OUT
OF PLACE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR PAN SENATOR PER YEAR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
DOCTOR COUNTY BY THE I BELIEVE
THAT THE WAY THAT THE THAT IT'S
REGULATED BY THE FDA IS YOU
NEED A PHARMACY DIRECTOR YOU
MAY HAVE TO HAVE TO IDENTIFY
SOMEBODY AS THE DIRECTOR WHO'S
IN CHARGE- BUT- FRANKLY. THE
THAT THE ISSUE MAYBE WE CAN
LOOK AT CALLING IT SOMETHING
ELSE BUT THE ISSUE IS JUST
SOMEBODY HAS TO BE IN CHARGE
OF. OF OF THE WHOLE PROCESS AND
IT TO THE CLOSED LOOP PROCESS
THERE'S NOTHING COMPLICATED
ABOUT IT- BOB FIVE SEEN THAT IN
THE OPPOSITION WANT TO TALK TO
THEM AND ALSO TALK TO THE
PHARMACY BOARD TO SEE IF
THERE'S SOME RESOLUTION THAT
WILL. SATISFY THAT PARTICULAR
REQUIREMENT I THINK THE ISSUE
YOU KNOW THAT THE BIGGEST
CONCERN IS EIGHT. IS THIS IDEA
THAT YOU'RE MAKING SOMEBODY A
DIRECTOR OF SOMETHING BUT I
THINK IT JUST HAS TO BE
SOMEBODY IN CHARGE. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FOR YOUR
I. BOATS BOAT- THIS IS WORK
DURING THIS PANDEMIC IT IT IS-
COMMONSENSE AND PROVIDE REAL
RESOURCES FOR THE COMMUNITY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
DODD THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM EIGHT SENATE
BILL FOUR ZERO NINE SENATOR
CABALLERO DO YOU PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH HI. ROTH
AYE MELENDEZ AYE MELENDEZ AYE
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D FAITH
HI EIGHT I BACKER AYE BECKER
AYE DODD. DODD AYE EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN I HER TADO NINE PER
TANTO I JONES HI JONES I LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE MIN NEWMAN. HI
NEWMAN AYE AYE CHAU ABODE I A
SHOW ABOUT A GUY HAN HI CAN I.
THE. THIRTY THE VOTE IS
THIRTEEN- ZERO KNOWS WILL PUT
THAT THE LONG CALL. AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY. SO LET'S. OPEN
THE ROLE FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM ONE SENATE BILL FORTY
EIGHT SENATOR LEE MONNING D.
PASSES AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS FAITH. BATES
AYE HER TADO. CAN.
ELEVEN FINAL
VOTE SIZE ELEVEN KNOWS ONE.
BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM TWO SENATE
BILL TWO ONE SIX SENATOR DODD
THE PAST AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FAITH FIVE EIGHT FIVE BACKER.
BAKER II. FOURTEEN FINAL VOTE
FOURTEEN ZEROS THOSE ARE. FILE
ITEM THREE SENATE BILL TWO SIX
THREE SENATOR RUBIO DO YOU PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS MELENDEZ.
FINAL VOTE CLOSE ONE THOUGH TWO
SIX RESULT. FILE ITEM SIX
SENATE BILL THREE ONE ZERO
SENATOR RUBIO THE PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY MELENDEZ. HER TADO.
AT. MELENDEZ HI MEMBERS IF I
COULD REMIND YOU TO PLEASE TURN
ON YOUR MICROPHONE UNTIL A
BOGEY HI A CHIP. THE SHOW ABOUT
A GUY. THE FIREBOAT FOURTEEN
AYE SERRANO BILLS OUT. FILE
ITEM FIVE SENATE BILL TWO NINE
SEVEN SENATOR DORADO DE PASSES
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY MELENDEZ AYE.
MELENDEZ AYE BATES. BATES I.
FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN ZERO BILLS
UP. FILE ITEM FOR SENATE BILL
TWO EIGHT FIVE SENATOR MCGUIRE
DO YOU PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FACTOR. BAKER I. IS FOR WORKING.
FIND ABOUT FOURTEEN ZERO BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM SEVEN SENATE
BILL THREE SEVEN SEVEN SENATOR
ARCHULETA. D. PASSANT RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY MELENDEZ. BATES LOW SIX
NARROW BAKER. BAKER I EGGMAN.
NEWMAN A SHOW ABOUT. FINAL VOTE
EIGHT TO TWO ADA'S TWO KNOWS
BILLS OUT. ALREADY. FIVE WE HAD
REPORTED THAT. FILE ITEM SEVEN
EXCUSE ME FILE ITEM NINE SENATE
BILL FOUR EIGHT FOUR SENATE
MITCHELL LET ACT DEEP PASSES
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BECKER. BY BAKER
II EGGMAN. MILLION FIVE MILLION
AYE NEWMAN. PAN.
FILE ITEM NINE
THE VOTERS ELEVEN ZERO BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM EIGHT SENATE
BILL FOUR ZERO NINE SENATOR
CAFIERO DO YOU PASS IN A RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. MAN HI MAN I.
FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN ZERO BILL
AS A. AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
MATTERS. YEAH THANK YOU TO ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO VERIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO BE SURE TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. IS CONCERNED.